what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame everyone club yay all right
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell the way you're gonna
be notified of my daily videos like the
video on your way in and make sure you
subscribe to my two clips channels just
for eclipse and pearl daily
um that you have to sign up for our five
dollar tier to be a part of the
memberships or to be a part of the chat
tonight
um King how many likes are we gonna do
to open up the chat
a thousand five hundred likes and we
will open up the chat so make sure you
send the like button and over what
number Super chats are we gonna read
and over twenty dollars we will read
your super chat so um today we have a
lovely panel so why don't we go around
everyone say your name your age your
relationship status and a fun fact about
yourself starting here and then going
around so my name's Hannah and I'm 20.
I'm 25 then but I've been absolutely
really live there in 2027
um from South East London I'm single
a fun fact about myself or God
I burst out into song anytime any day
any place any given moment you burst out
and understand yeah okay yeah
are you a singer or something no oh okay
you just like to sing all right go ahead
hi guys my name's Tia I'm 25.
um I live in Heathrow and I sell hair
um and I'm engaged
hello my name is anush I'm 22 years old
fun fact about me is that I just start a
podcast
from California
hey guys I am Dimitri I am 40 years old
I'm married with four kids and a fun
fact about me uh is I think that aramco
is just the greatest Oil Company in the
world
um am I sponsored by Big Oil I don't
know but I just think aramco is amazing
and uh just a shout out there to mknmg
go ramko
my name is Craig I'm 35 years old I'm
from London in my spare time at the
podcast my spare time
my name is Rick Frost I'm a creative
director I'm 35 years of age
um fun fact about me I worn many
different hats in the entertainment
industry over a long period of time so
yeah well welcome to the show everybody
so today
um we are going to be talking about
this week
there was a tweet that erupted Twitter
all right this tweet had all the women
mad on the right and the left it had the
men mad and the Tweet was um can you
pull up the one the original one I sent
you
the
the mar the Brad Pratt one
so and how did you guys know who Margot
Robbie is yes okay so there was a tweet
that said despite years of complaining
about unrealistic beauty standards the
most talked about movie of the year is
of two insanely hot people and it had a
picture of Barbie okay and Margot
Robbie's the star and in um Barbie so
but someone quote tweeted that and said
Margot Robbie was cast in Barbie
explicitly because she wasn't pretty
enough
to alienate a female audience
and this erupted
Twitter
because they felt like they were just
dogging on her looks they felt like
um and then there was a
bunch of people who basically were
calling Margot Robbie mitt
so my question to you is what would you
rate Margot Robbie one to ten we're
going to show her picture in a second
can you pull it up King
Margot Robbie one to ten
in this photo or just in general in
general
in general I'd give her a 10 but
probably in this fight I God you can
tell there's just like so much
post-production on it she doesn't
actually look real but then she's not
trying to just can you can you just
Google her too and we can just show some
other pictures
but like day to day I would say yeah
she's a good solid nine nine nine ten
nine ten yeah I think I haven't seen
that before but from what I'm looking at
she looks
okay
um she's definitely someone the industry
uses as like a beauty standard yeah
I would say seven seven
I'll give her like a
8.25 8.2 what do you think oh she's a
ton ten eight eight she's a strong nine
nine yeah definitely okay but my
question is this why can men not
criticize a woman's looks
without erupting the internet
are we going in order yeah anyone can
just
I would say because
women's looks are known to be uh
important factor in something that they
can often be sensitive about I think
societally
it's a little bit taboo to speak about
and can come across offensive and you
know as they say misogynistic so but if
we but if we like criticize a guy's
looks nobody cares like if I called
Leonardo DiCaprio mid no one would care
that's true you know what I mean but
he's the one dating all the models but
nobody would care yeah yeah I think it's
because men uh Society knows men
personally don't put as much of as an
emphasis on their own looks it's not as
much of a factor um maybe in their
confidence you could say that it's a
little bit
easier to to make fun of them versus
women it's like be careful you don't
want to hurt her feelings
what do you guys think
um me personally I feel like yeah
females females in general are emotional
beings I think that's fair to say and I
don't feel like it's a man's place to
even speak on
um
the looks or if they feel like a woman
is like oh really attractive especially
on social media I think that's
it's a bit of a low blow um
so
yeah do women speak and if men are
attractive on social media absolutely so
why does one gender get to do it and not
the other privilege yeah privilege
no but you're saying you but I'm asking
you because you said you don't think men
should comment on women's looks but I'm
saying if the women are doing it why
can't the man
it's just it's taboo isn't it yeah yeah
it's just like one of those it's like an
unspoken rule but
it shouldn't be was was one rule for one
and another and another rule for another
it shouldn't be that way at all like
imagine have you ever heard like um
short man syndrome yeah like what if
what if they had small tits syndrome
we can't do that you know
what do you think Dimitri but there's so
much to unpack here I mean how how deep
do we want to dwell into this go go deep
oh man okay so this is this is actually
there's quite a lot of interesting stuff
here so um I was reading some studies
I'm doing a book called The Book of
Shame where I'm literally putting
together
um 300 and sorry 403
no 304 yeah 304. um but once you have
the 304 studies that sort of outline the
difference between virtue signaling and
actual outcomes in society and one thing
of course we already know is that what
we say and what we think are not the
same thing one very basic example of
that like I did a clip where it's like
the most discriminated group when you
look at across any group for like
controlled for race and looks and age
and everything the most discriminator
Group by far are short men and it's not
close like short men of the highest
suicide rates short rate men have the
highest um rates of of drinking and
binge drinking highest depression uh
lowest income Etc et cetera Etc and I'm
not saying that like short man can be
successful I think they can and should
be it's more so that we just know the
outcomes for short men are terrible
short men also are vastly
underrepresented in the sexual
Marketplace like women are just not
picking them in fact when you look at
like the searches right this is just
numbers like you're looking on search on
um what is it the dating app everybody's
using nowadays
fumble whatever uh oh it's the women
filter out yeah under six foot tall to
show up in less than 15 of searches so
they don't even get they don't even get
looked up I was thinking about that I'm
like I If I Was A short guy I would just
lie on the dating apps I understand why
they do it because I'm like women lie
with the filters who lie with the makeup
I'm like if I was a guy I would lie on
make it even do it too right well and so
so the question is like okay so then why
do we make a taboo so there's there's a
few steps here why it is so so
um virtue signaling is actually like a
very well-known mating tactic uh applied
by both men and women the way that men
virtue signal is they become more
altruistic around women they perceive to
be beautiful so when you have like a
charity event men will give more money
when a beautiful woman's in the room
it's been tested it's been shown many
many times over women virtue signal
Purity so women will drop hints that
they're sexually pure despite the fact
that they might tell you on this podcast
like oh it doesn't matter how many guys
you sleep with but but
when you actually look at Women's
behavior and women's and and how they
they express their behavior they always
express their behaviors being sexually
cleaner than their actual Behavior this
is not conjecture this is study then
this is true right so why not why not
say like a woman blah blah blah well
very simply uh because a woman's value
is implicitly determined by how
attractive she is to potential mates and
the way that we know this there's a
really cool study about this is they did
a study on how good are women and men at
perceiving the beauty of other women so
they gave uh really yes and so and so
what they found is men consistently pick
the same women as being beautiful women
are highly cognizant and extremely good
at identifying which women are beautiful
to other men and the women that are most
beautiful to other men when they are in
the room women become derogatory towards
the most beautiful women wow yes because
they want to undermine and what they do
is they undermine her Chastity and her
Purity she's like oh she's a [__] she's
this and that and the reason they're
saying it is because they want to
relative so women compete relatively
with each other as well and so they
undermine the sexual market value of
other women in the room
right and by the way you never see guys
do this right it's like oh that guy's a
piece of crap like guys don't do that
because it comes off as inherently
feminine so guys don't compete like that
we compete physically much more direct
now here's what's interesting when men
were asked to raid the attractiveness of
other men men are notoriously bad at at
actualizing like which other men are
attractive to women and it's very easy
to prove because like I can talk to a
new show any other guys here I can say
look guys have you ever seen a guy that
consistently gets beautiful women and
you're like how does he do that Pete
Davidson right yeah so we got what the
hell so men are actually very bad at
perceiving the attractiveness of other
men to women so we might we might think
that guy's a loser but he's getting all
the tricks like what's going on right
well because is it because men are more
logical no so like but like women we
pick based off of emotions a lot of the
time no it's no it's because well
obviously that's true but also but but
it's more so to do with the fact that
men compete on status so it's like so
but the question is like so why can't we
uh objectively say something about a
woman and the answer is very clear and
here it is it's because we all know
like we look at Margot Robbie we can
play the game like ah she's a 7.8 it's
like dude she's literally she played
Sharon Tate and Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood who was the standard of Beauty
for like two generations she's literally
like you might say she's not your type
whatever but objectively find a woman
that's subjectively more beautiful good
luck yeah you know you know what's
interesting though I've found on this
show that when I ask men versus women
women will rate her higher than men do
like I don't know why because I always
thought she was like the epitome of
beauty right but every time I've like
brought her up as like the number one
like Beauty staff yeah do you have other
women on the couch women
um when men say that other women around
them yeah the men are virtually no no
but we they'll usually do is they'll
bring up like the most common one I got
is the what is that preacher's wife I
think she just divorced him
um
I cannot remember her name yeah I get
Megan Good a lot and I get
um uh
uh the Russell Wilson's wife now I get
her a lot I like yeah I get those two
more than Margot Robbie weirdly enough
well look she might she there's
different levels whatever but like
objectively speaking oh yeah yeah like
like she's like she's like like you're
not gonna oh and I want better it's like
okay so I wanted I wanted to redo some
of the responses
um towards towards them because I just I
wasn't even interested like obviously
she's hot right but I was more
interested in how like viscerally
everybody reacted because I was like if
I said I don't think Leonardo DiCaprio
is that hot I don't think Michael B
Jordan's that hot like whatever like sex
status of like the guy equivalent no one
would really care but so I was thinking
like I think women reacted so viscerally
to this because if men don't perceive
her as attractive like what does that
make us that I like the average chick
you know what I mean so
um
there was like the guys would come in
and said I want everybody who says
Margot Robbie isn't attractive enough to
play Barbie to post photos of your wives
and girlfriends I'm trying to see
something exactly but but the thing is
like I I think the question more is like
because people will attack the people
instead of the argument like is she mid
or is she not mad and you could say
objectively she's not but like what is a
person's like girlfriend have to do with
it listen I'm sorry for taking up some
space here but like let's get serious
like if somebody approached me in front
of my wife and said how hot is Margot
Robbie I would be incentivized to Virtue
single big well you know there's a lot
of dudes out there that can't pick up a
eight or nine which is just how it is
and it's fine that's okay like they're
we're working on ourselves this man
right and they virtue signal to say like
well she's not even that hot it's like
dude she's not picking you like show
some damn respect and just like live up
to where you are and and just say the
truth you know unhinged take if you ever
get it in your head that Margot Robbie
isn't in the top five percent of
conventionally attractive women log off
go for a walk outside Sally say hello to
a normal looking female return and
correct yourself
um and it was interesting I put I just
I've been doing this before the show I
put it in
um Google just a picture of her now I
wish I did one without makeup but I
guess guess what her rating was can you
guys see it don't look she can see it
um but one to ten what do you think
because they had like you basically
basically put the picture in and then
men rate her one to ten yeah so that was
like is she mid let's look
guess guess what percent attractiveness
she's in sin yeah like top 10 top 20.
yeah top ten I would say something yeah
top ten top ten percent so they are
chatting [__] but but I was more curious
about the reaction so this led me today
was I was hoping as a class as a group
we can find celebrities and examples
rate people one to ten
yeah so I I was thinking
I was thinking like what the men pick
and what the women pick as like a 10 in
each rating
so
should I do this one king
the other one
sorry
all right what's an example
first thing that comes into your hand
had don't say Margot Robbie of a 10.
let's everybody everybody okay
hmm
male or female
we'll do mail next we'll do mail next
Jessica Alba tends to exist
Jessica Alba
is it Adriana Lima Lena the Victorious
the Victoria's Secret model what's her
name Adriana Lima Lena
I'm not sure
which one is that um
she's been she's been uh yeah yeah it's
been a Victoria's Secret model for years
I'm not sure I think Victoria
yeah
I'll say Louis Harvey oh that's a good
one she's beautiful
story
RV
and King if you can during some of these
can you pull up pictures of them on the
screen
um who else are we speaking like purely
aesthetic yeah just looks okay
I can't even think no well I've been
putting the pressure
I'd actually agree with Dimitri Jessica
Alba is a good example Jessica Alba okay
what about a five
oh
it'd be good if we could see some
examples
um Sarah Jessica Parker maybe oh that's
a good one
Sarah and
put Sarah Jessica Parker on the screen
and see if they think she's a
a five
a few years back why would you rate her
one to ten
hey
um
I don't think that's doing her any
justice
go back go back like 15 years come on
[Laughter]
I'm rough we're looking at Heyday she
was definitely she was on the five no
she she was well above a 500 yeah
bruh
she's a six at best I mean look this is
relative right like you could say she's
a Suggs but like you go on the street
I've been I've been in London for two
days right she would literally be the
most beautiful woman in London like
today she'd be in the top two percent of
the city like like it's just what it is
right all right we're gonna do all right
raise your hand if you think she's a
four oh no no
no raise your hand if you think she's a
five
I would say five sorry what what age are
we ranking her at let's do put her put
her out like I don't know 35 you don't
want to put her in her prime and see
what
I mean we could do Prime I don't know
here just pick a picture King
what would you put her out in the middle
seven six seven yeah okay so we'll do
we'll do the middle pictures six
okay
Sarah
Jessica
Parker
Pearl I got one for you okay again
Markle
what is she
oh you want me to say yeah what do you
rate her one can we pull up a picture
over
gotta refresh
giving her a
qua
I was gonna say seven and a half yeah
all right who thinks she's a seven raise
your hand
who thinks she's an eight
eight okay
let's go ahead and throw Megan Fox
there's a ton I was just thanking her
yeah
Dimitri has all the references
from 10 years ago
um okay okay lizzo
10.
sorry on which lizzo lizzo's got to be
on this hat I think about 3 20 last time
I checked
lizzo one to ten
zero zero
three three
all right who thinks who thinks she's
one lizzo is that the lowest yeah who
thinks she's I'm gonna be respectful and
give her like a solid too
all right who thinks she's a two three
two or three three who thinks she's a
three
maybe am I being too generous too
generous I say three then what's the one
but again but again it was a preference
it's preference
of Personality yeah exactly well there
was none of this when we were doing the
hot chicks why does this switch when
they're not hot no I I personally
believe it's not the preference because
she's a fluffy female and I do believe
that she's still beautiful but she's not
my personal preference yes I'm asking
you what you would Raider yeah me
personally I would put her down as like
a two three all right a three all right
all right who says two
who says three
who says one
all right
okay I guess one I think it's the most I
think the word the word you're looking
for the word you're looking for is the
planet
all right lizzo's one
all right
um
what would Rosie O'Donnell be similar to
a one yeah Rosie I don't know yeah
oh yeah I remember
Judy yeah
let's just see if they gave me anyone in
the chat sometimes they'll do that
all right guys if you have any girls in
the chat you want everybody to write
um someone put Jody Comer does anyone
know who that is
they're just trolling their friend's mom
Rosie O'Donald
one is lizzo hotter than Rosie
I mean she's probably hotter like
physically in terms of like she just
needs a lot of air conditioning in the
room but all right Rosie O'Donnell oh
what about Gemma Collins oh that's a
good one I've put up Jenna Collins
Jay
spelled with a G yeah yeah
what would she be
all right who thinks who thinks of four
three yeah not knowing her
a three a three see I would say lizzo
ranked higher than her yeah I love Gemma
I love I think she's brilliant but
yeah did I think it largely depends on
how how much are you weighing the the
fat Factor because if you're purely like
it's how scientific you want to get what
the facialistic look here I'm asking I'm
asking you it's not what everyone else
thinks it's what you think like you
would rate her one to ten I'd give her a
three I'd give her a three
I personally if we're gonna give her a
three I'm saying Lisa has to get a four
you think Liz was more attractive yeah
oh actually without the makeup wow she
looks different you see the black top
um okay I would say three for this check
I would have gave lizzo like a two
um what do you think one to one to five
this one yeah this one I mean like she's
a one but she kind of has that American
Pie MILF points I'd give her two two all
right what do you say one one
yes it has to be a two two what do you
say probably a one too
one one what about what about you
two two
one all right what was her name again
Gemma Collins
I Just Want to Thank You Pearl you know
spending a lot of time around corporate
we just never get to do this at work
look it
what about Rihanna
nine damn nine yeah
I think she's like eight to go to two
this is
okay we'll do we'll do Maya first just
because she's on the screen
okay
[Music]
um
I give her a
again I feel like she's a solid nine
yeah
he's got a nice body as well yeah
Beyonce 10 10.
what
are you kidding me see this one now is a
bit again taboo I think I think Beyonce
is an eight go go to like go to like go
to like her and like Austin Powers 3H
like when she's like Prime
Beyonce has always been beautiful let's
keep it real but I don't know if she's a
she's a 10. I feel like she's
what about Dodger cat
wait we'll do her next but we'll do be
okay Beyonce raise your hand if you
think she's an eight we're going with
current
yeah current yeah eight eight nine I'm
not eight and a half yeah enough nine
ten
okay I think the average would be nine
so Beyonce
there's a nine Doja cat
hmm it's getting tricky
again it's an acquired taste now I'm
asking you what you're tasting it's not
other people she has too many different
faces to be honest with you I don't
wanna even later on like she she she's
she's a great creative but I I don't I
don't even know
okay yeah like there's not one face
there that could say it's the same
person like it's mad
what do you guys think
six to seven yep seven seven
yeah seven
we need a five
what about scissor
is that how you pronounce her name yeah
yeah
I said a what the real one of the
plastic one the plastic one
she's in the five range I mean this is
the real one yeah
let's see the plastic one
the plastic one
what about Khloe Kardashian yeah
what was your next but this one this
girl first scissor scissor Denise is uh
I would rate her
a mine hold on so she's done work yeah
so that was her before with the curly
hair
for the cast is on
you see her currently now
she looks good
okay this picture one to ten
I'd give her like I give her like a six
I'm I'm at a seven seven yeah seven
seven I'm a five five
seven seven this picture yes seven seven
probably not like five like she looks
like it's like I've seen a bit of a bad
dream
well that sounds really horrible but uh
yeah it's quite easy I want to do is a
six it's like an average
um okay Khloe Kardashian
now now Khloe Kardashian now
we have to be more picture of her
I'd say probably like seven
seven
six oh I don't know about that first
I don't know oh yeah
yeah are all of them her yeah what
I think she actually looks good now but
I I can't get with the work man
I do sex what would you guys do yeah
we cannot find a five I'll give her a
five what about Adele
oh that's a good one Adele Adele with
like her weight loss
Chloe
Kardashian
Adele
before or after after
I'd say probably a good solid yeah she
looks good oh what was give me the
before and the after what would you guys
rate her before she lost weight and
after um
that's a good one
three and eight
three and eight three and eight
doll
I'll say five and eight
five and eight
but don't this picture yeah I'm saying
I'm saying foreign
what would you say
ing
three and eight
I think I got we're really we're really
taking a dump on the body positivity
movement here hey it's like we're like
well and it's actually this is very
interesting because
um we know inherently that like being
fit is more attractive period end of
sentence right
um I'll share a cool little stat that I
I looked up recently I thought was
pretty funny
um do you guys think that being
attractive helps you like let's say
you're at work right do you guys think
being attractive helps you like earn
more money or your life over your
lifetime absolutely yes the numbers are
staggering so uh more attractive people
earn on average it's uh about five
thousand dollars a year than less
attractive people which is like 230 000
over the course of a career but if you
were to take that money and split them
to like monthly payments or whatever is
like 411 a month something like that if
you invest that if you take the add
added income that people that are more
attractive earn over less attractive
people if you just invest that in the
stock market over the course of your
career it works out to 3.8 million
dollars that attractive people make over
unattractive people but that's not the
crazy stat here's all the crazy stat you
might enjoy this because when I was
reading those statistics I was like oh
women really get punished at work for
not being like more attractive but
actually men get punished wait
disproportionately men women get
punished way more for being on a trip
well women also have higher men have
higher beauty standards than women do
like this whole like women have the
highest beauty standards that we can't
live up to men find like half of us
attractive that's true it's like it's
like stupid like I couldn't believe like
the guy the girls like guys will
say they would like sleep down so much
you know what I mean like it's crazy
when you go down to like how low they'll
go but women it's like we only find like
five to fifteen percent of men
attractive 20 on the correlation of 0.6
which is like unheard of in sociology
but 0.6 correlation to a man's status so
for a man to be more attractive to women
like so again when women rate men they
don't agree on who's more attractive
without any context but once you put
clothing on that man like you got a guy
in a suit you got a guy in a t-shirt
they consistently go for the status
right so women have a very very strong
correlation to being attracted to status
so I'm curious from the guys
if a girl is an eight
but
she's got a kid what is she
one as a kid minus how much invincible
she's an eight but she's got a kid what
is she I literally had this dinner
conversation with one of my colleagues
like just now
he's like knowing what you know about
your wife like everything she's the same
person looks the same acts the same the
same exact person but you meet her when
she is a kid I'm like yeah I would not
even know her name by the way you guys
she has a kid she's an eight with a kid
what is she I mean purely aesthetically
I don't think it would yeah no I'm
saying like in terms of like dating
it's okay we don't have to be a bpc
not sure maybe brother you're 22. if you
say anything but a zero we're gonna have
a talk after the show and I'm gonna I'm
gonna give you some old man wisdom
I'll say uh four or five okay so minus
four a kid all right we're gonna have a
talk if you were my kid I'd be like son
sit down what do you guys say minus what
she's got a kid for me it doesn't really
matter zero yeah
all right well average you're minus
minus zero points don't care zero points
sorry
okay I don't want to Stack myself on
here but like dude like so did you know
did you know that once a woman has a kid
she carries that kid's DNA forever and
it doesn't just go into the womb it goes
straight to her heart there's actual
signs to show that that kid's DNA which
means another man's DNA is living inside
that woman and now you're producing kids
with a woman who's like DNA is like
mixed with another dude that's is that
even uh
his life his life though
yeah but you can make choices yeah
no no no no no no no no no no no it's
life you can get pregnant like three
days a month I am so tired of like oh it
just happened
in as much as I'm talking about like the
choices of being with somebody that's
got a child or not like I think it's
just not the preference at the end of
the day
um I'm an older man so I don't see so
kid no kid they're exactly the same to
you yeah like if you're beautiful and
like my intention with yourself is the
same we've got Pure intentions and it is
what it is no but I'm saying like you
have two girls they're exactly the same
both equally hot one has a kid one
doesn't you're picking which one if it's
a choice between two then you should be
the one without the child okay so it
does subtract something
if it's a choice between two people yeah
correct but that's what I'm saying like
like you're saying it wouldn't make a
difference but it would
because you just admitted it would
oh okay okay
be honest come on like you know what
makes a difference
for myself it hasn't made too much of a
difference like in in my past
relationships but
maybe maybe
moving forward
if I had two females that I deemed to be
eight one had a child and one didn't I
would go for the one that didn't have a
job okay so minus one maybe minus one
thank you honestly what about you
girls
girls name one has a kid one doesn't
depends it depends the person that
treats you right in the day no they
treat you the same just one has a kid
one doesn't I'll go for one hat doesn't
have a kid okay so so minus one minus
one yeah thank you thank you
I'm gonna do an average of three because
you said Infinity what's what like
what's the intent right like for example
if you're a single guy and you're just
hooking up whatever you might not
consider it right but like at some age
you become a more serious man and you
wanna you know you wanna take the danger
that you've built on yourself and turn
it into like a sagacious commitment and
become a more virtuous man like there is
age-appropriate problems you have to
solve right and it's like you work
really hard gents you know and and this
guy here told me he's an entrepreneur
before it's like yeah you're gonna risk
50 of everything you've ever earned
before and after you're you're through
with that relationship you're gonna risk
it on somebody that gave her genetics to
somebody else at the beginning like
that's a dangerous thing I didn't say
I'll risk it well you didn't say you
would marry her maybe right yeah so what
at 22 maybe it doesn't make a difference
but as you get older and you start
solving older men problems you look for
long-term relationships somebody to
raise your children yeah that's a that's
a more difficult choice no definitely be
a harsh knock for sure but I was
speaking purely aesthetically yeah
and your perception of that fair okay
fair I buy oh and only fans is minus
what
so what was that a girl she's an eight
but she's got an only fans what is she
now
conversation
she's done yeah Danza okay so negative
10. yeah okay what about you negative
ten as well negative ten minus ten
thousand dollars a month you're paying
my my lifestyle Sugar Mama all right
what about you say four minus all right
so we'll do minus eight for only fans
all right she's innate
but she slept with two of your friends
what is she
you're coming with him now
as far as the rankings negative 100
they're putting in the chat yeah it's
just Pete now oh it's danzo I wouldn't
say it's danzo because yeah
sometimes the it's good for the Ganges
so she might be not like a five baby all
right so minus three for two of your
friends what about you one minus one
zero go away no chance no chance zero
are you dude I'm not that's like that's
mean to my friends oh okay like that's
like come on like like that's so scarce
to think that a dude would pick up and
like a no all right so we got negative
10 negative one I think you guys have a
very wide range here let me see we're
gonna do negative uh what about you yeah
mine is mine zero as well we're gonna do
negative five for two friends
okay
she's an eight but
she's slapped
um what number do I want to do today she
slept with 15 guys what is she now
being guys
she's not an option dunzo
zero zero zero zero see
four or five purely aesthetically
all right we're gonna do negative eight
for ten bodies or fifteen bodies
are you noticing the trend
what are you noticing the trend
man just wants to bust nuts he's 20 he's
22.
being being generous perception wise
yeah but he's 22 we can like we've all
been 22. yeah we've dubbed in the pool
you know we've scraped the bottom some
barrels
all right let's ask the ladies
all right he's an eight
but he doesn't have a job
what you're in the bin oh gone done so
what about what if they have ambition or
gold she's applying for jobs she just
doesn't have one has he it depends on
what his Earth what Earth I mean he
applied at McDonald's you know what I
mean
um
yeah no I I feel like me as an
individual I'm quite highly ambitious
and I
just don't find it in attractive in a
gentleman that if they don't if they
just if they haven't got that sort of
ambition in that drive to get up and
actually want to go and do and yeah so
you're in the binge Okay negative 10
what about you if they have the ambition
and the goal and they're putting their
mind towards something or they're trying
to find a job in a certain sector and I
can see you're trying hard and you're
going to interviews and you know like
that
I'll give you
seven
so it might just minus one yeah as long
as he's good as long as he's going to
some interviews yeah like all right you
ambitious and going out every day how
ambitious like what does he have to be
applying to
um so if he's got his mind and his goal
towards something like this set job that
he wants and he's doing his research
he's continuously going on interviews
then that's different if you're just
being a bum when you're staying at home
and you're not trying to look for work
or not trying to focus on your career or
try and Elevate yourself then so
negative
negative for that one yeah and negative
10. all right negative 10 no job
okay
he's an eight but he has a kid
depends on what the Bible I'm saying
um
it's quite a hard question
do you think that guys leave their baby
mums
do you mean like so do you think like
the baby mum will be completely out of
their life no and I would never expect
them to be
um do you feel like there's a chance to
going back sorry no well I don't know
I'm single to be honest so I wouldn't
know myself I've never been put in that
situation so I wouldn't know but
oh
if their baby mum was a bit
a bit crazy you know okay probably okay
let's do a good baby mom and a bad baby
mom so he's got a kid with a good baby
mom negative one for me wouldn't bother
you no okay bad baby mom
you're done yeah minus ten minus ten
okay he's an eight
but but
he's got a bit of a beer belly
[Laughter]
is it a bear belly or money belly
so say money buddy I
don't understand
probably like
minus eight yeah minus eight yeah for a
beer belly but you know what I don't
really I'm not a big drinker and I
yeah
no it's because he's a drinker yeah it's
not the look no so no the little one
probably about yeah six or an eight do
tattoos add or subtract for you add add
yeah
in the middle and neutral yeah what
about you guys tattoos on a woman add or
subtract I love
at add at how much
[Music]
we'll see what I look for you I'm not
supposed to look for females with
tattoos but it's definitely at some
pointers so maybe like one or two points
so if I got like a sleeve I'd get a
point yeah okay
add minus five to start and then that's
the that's the minus starting point and
then drops from there depending on
location and size what about you yeah
subtract at least like two three two
three yeah
I think
tattoos I don't like tattoos on a guy I
prefer none but I don't really care that
much I feel like it doesn't really make
a difference um
okay
he's an eight
but but but
he has a horrible relationship with his
mom do you guys care yeah yeah why have
you had a bad experience with a guy that
like doesn't get along with his mom yeah
once once yeah I didn't I I'm such a
family person and for me family is the
most important thing and if someone
doesn't get on with their mum
then there's obviously a reason behind
that and for me that's like quite a big
red flag because
yeah no I just wouldn't if they didn't
get on with their mom I'd be like I
don't know I'm where I'm such a family
person and I adore my family around me
24 7. like I've not got kids but if I
had a kid I know my kid could kill
someone blue bloody murder and I'd turn
a blind eye to it and I'd still love
them no matter what so if someone
doesn't speak to their mum and that is a
big big red flag
so you don't care too much about their
family like at the same I agree oh you
agree what about you guys you guys look
at her family background me 110
definitely definitely what do you look
at in her family background
Dynamic is a big thing
like with Mom Dad like both both parents
and how the how the family functions
together
what's a bigger red flag if she doesn't
get along with her mom or her dad father
for sure
what about you Dimitri yeah of course so
you know there's this there's this crazy
thing right now where like you know the
Jonah hilltops I'm sure you guys
discussed it here it's like he sets out
some boundaries which are pretty rate
like they're not crazy boundaries it's
like hey I don't want you going on with
your [__] friends like like because
you've broken my trust people like it's
controlling and I kind of read that I
was like okay I think a lot of women say
that's controlling because they just
never have proper boundaries set in
their life and like I'm a dad I got four
kids you know what a dad's role is in a
in a child's life in a girl or boy's
life it's to set boundaries like you
know if you look at like when how kids
go to bed if Mom puts kids to bed they
tend to extend going to bed by like half
an hour to an hour but when dad puts
kids to bed they go to bed right away
dad's word is firmer kids oblige and
test that they oblige more to the dad
they test the dad less so if she doesn't
have a like a good relationship with her
father she's growing up without a dad
there's no boundary set for her so she
perceives boundaries as emotional abuse
but our boundaries necessary in
relationships yeah especially explicit
boundaries like we have to understand
what exactly works for us and what
doesn't and that's okay so no one of the
best pieces of advice I ever received
when I was about 22 from a mentors he
said look at that woman's relationship
with her father and it'll tell you how
she treats you yeah do you guys look at
like how much makeup she wears yes how
much can that subtractor add to a girl
make or break yeah
what is it what does it do
at least four points three to four
subtraction yeah why
because I mean it's a preference thing
but also it's you're almost dealing with
a different person at that point like
you can look like two completely
different people so it's just a little
bit inauthentic in my opinion have you
guys ever gone on a date with a girl and
you like woke up and she looked
completely different
no no fortunately I think seeing seeing
people with or without uh makeup can be
night and day difference yeah
unrecognizable a lot of the time really
yeah you're nodding really hard no I
mean look like women are going to wear
makeup like that's just how it is and
there should be a level that you take
care of yourself but obviously you know
the trend right now and like every time
I come to England I see these weird
puffer face like it's just fake I they
shave their I don't know what the hell's
going on I've drawn on eyebrows well I
don't know I like it was crazy doing the
show for so long because girls would
follow me after the show and a lot of
times I'll follow people back but like
sometimes I wouldn't recognize them
I'm like wait is that the girl I was
because they'll tag me in their stories
and I'm like oh my god I didn't even
notice but then I was like this is why
the guys are complaining on the dating
apps huh have you guys ever gone on like
a date with a girl from a dating app and
she looked different
do you know what no he said he was like
six foot three and he was about six foot
three so that I was quite pleased with
but he didn't nothing like his five
sides
at all like there's catfishing and then
there's that like they were him but I
don't know why I don't know what he does
but it was like from like 10 years ago
he was a bit older as well he said to me
he was 24. this is when I was like 22.
oh he lied about it yeah he was about 35
36 and obviously that each to their own
you know I mean everyone has their own
preference and and whatever I completely
understand I completely respect that but
I was just you know when you're just a
bit shocked you're like oh what are you
God what am I gonna do it like I'm too
nice to run away and then no I am oh I
was I had to sit there and we're staring
at the hotel New section about for a
drink after I'm like yeah I've got to go
home I've got oats in my own sorry I've
done that before where you're like oh I
want to leave but you're like you don't
want to like yeah you don't want to hurt
someone's feelings like and it's like
because I know I wouldn't like someone
to do it to me personally but and so I
just couldn't do it to someone else and
like that look of like dishearten like
just being someone who's disheartening
and they've been together for eight
years now what do you perfect age to
date for you guys
hmm
two years two years older two years
older two maybe a year younger two years
older okay three years maybe four that's
no more than that okay I'd say what
about you
um yeah I'll say two years older
okay
to say plus minus two but I think uh
issue with my age range is a lot of
people have a little bit maturity
differences so yeah I say plus minus two
well I married for 10 years we're the
same age we're about 40. yeah if you
were to date again what age would would
you do
um be careful Dimitri no that's actually
that's fine like no like that's actually
a really interesting question there's
some depth to it you know I'll tell you
you could even say if you had a friend
dating at your age no no I would say I
would say this like when I was when I
was let's say 25 26 and I was to be
asked if I find 40 year old women
attractive I would have said no like it
was just it'd be weird to think that way
but I've noticed myself now like uh my
like I still find my wife very beautiful
I like I do and if I didn't like we'd
have a problem
um and and I and I think like for me
like as I've gotten older I found like
now I look at a 20 year old chick and
I'm like that just looks like a teenager
to me yeah it's like you know when
you're in high school and you see a
college kid they look massive it becomes
the opposite when you get older I just
look at 20 I'm like are you like 15 like
I can't really tell that well anymore
it's crazy
um but I mean if
I mean realistically as a 40 year old
man probably anything 25
4 let's say enough is pretty reasonable
like checks it's a lot of it's like the
chicks still go for it yeah they do so
they're pretty wide range I mean look at
Pacino he just
had a kid with a 27 year old he's like
77 70 80. he's 80. I'm curious how how
old would you guys maybe if he looked
good would you date a 45 year old no no
40 no 35 No 30 oh excuse me you're not
35 yeah like 32 probably 33. no come on
like the most beautiful women in the
world are like look at Anthony kiedo's
from the from the Red Hot Chili Peppers
he's like 60 and like I would I wouldn't
have a problem 40 year old
Schwarzenegger's girlfriend's like 38 or
something he's 76 like like that you say
no because you want a virtue signal but
come on these guys aren't dating ugly 30
year olds they're dating beautiful 30
year olds yeah but is it because of
their status obviously it is obviously
it is I'm not so why would it not be of
course it is so if a man is high status
enough you're gonna be like no I'm sorry
like
Schwarzenegger like yeah it's like nah
you're gonna be like cool
do you not think it depends on what
someone or what depends on the
individual wants in the relationship
probably yeah
so but but again we're looking at high
status very old men that are like
pushing 80 or r80 and they still have
seemingly have no problem getting 26 and
30 year old women to want to be with
them so like I'm just looking at the big
data right but then like sorry if you
were to bring like a gold digger
situation oh sorry guys I know you're
okay uh you know what
um age men pecan dating apps for Plenty
of Fish probably around 42 of you might
guess say late 30s 37. it's crazy I was
so surprised when I saw this
that's about 35 I'd say probably 40 45
50. really yeah
guess what age women Peak 22. 28
I bet it's older but it's older I'll
probably say the same 18. yeah 18. 18 no
yeah yeah well they've done they've done
smell tests for a man and men will still
pick younger women just based on smell
yeah wow but for the men the 50 year
olds that are on there has to be like a
selected amount like has to be all
silver Foxes or a higher percentage
because
you wouldn't assume there's that many
average or below average 50 year olds on
Tinder you know
I mean there aren't most people on it
was plenty of fish but I think like
didn't you say 80 of people on dating
apps like don't get any yeah 50 of
people like if you get one match on like
Tinder then you're in the top 50 you're
like like half of men never get a match
ever I think I read this or I say this
somewhere online and it sure like if
you're most compatible you will show up
to more people whereas if you don't get
swapped so
five percent of the time so if you go on
a date with a guy from a dating app it's
it's probable that he like base he has a
ton of options because if you got on the
date that means like he's part of the
five percent that women are swiping on
most likely scary isn't it yeah yeah but
that's why relationships are so [__]
up because like that's the number one
way people are meeting under 30 nowadays
that's the number one way yeah is dating
apps so it's like all the girls are
going on the same dates with the same
guys I mean haven't you seen those
stories on like Tick Tock where the
girls are like oh my God we went on the
date with the same guy you know you know
what a great opportunity though like for
a man that is a little bit more Brave a
little bit more cunning like to to learn
how to approach and talk to women in
real life that like the premium on that
now the amount of points you get for
doing that now because so few because
when I was growing up right like again
I'm from I'm The Pretender generation
like I met my wife in real life that's
how people dated we'd walk around with
blue balls and we'd have to like be
desperate and approach women no but I
grew up in a time too like we didn't
have high speed internet when I was like
18 that was just coming in right and so
there was no visual stimulation to get
yourself off so you're just always horny
and that like that desperation you're
just like I'm just gonna approach and
talk to women because otherwise I'm
never gonna see a boob so it's like now
you know that's been completely like
destroyed Droid right men are just
destroying their own testosterone and
drive and risk seeking Behavior but for
a guy that's like a little bit more
ambitious if you learn that skill to
like approach women the premium you get
in status is insane because nobody's
doing it I agree I completely agree with
you in that completely agree if I was to
be approached somewhere it because no
one does it no no one does anything like
that nowadays yeah at all it's that
chivalry is pretty much in the pan yeah
because women killed it yeah they have
and I think it's it's probably a really
popular opinion like opinion coming from
a woman but like they have they totally
have they have because it's like women
will will call men creepy if they are
pro like I know so many guys that have
gotten no I don't want to say so many
but I've met guys that have like gotten
kicked out of gyms just for like looking
at a girl too long like someone will go
to the manager I know I know more than
one guy that's happened to yeah so it's
like but notice that they're getting
kicked out for not approaching that's
actually a big misconception you think
oh they're getting kicked out for
approaching though they're getting
kicked out like it's like the friend
zone thing like you're not in the friend
zone because because you asked her out
on major intent clear you're in the
friend zone because you didn't and you
didn't right so so that's actually a
really important distinction like if you
approach to check in the gym and you're
like hey you're really cute I know it's
the gym this is crazy okay whatever
whatever you say I'm not I'm not
purporting to be a PO you guys do your
thing right but getting that tension out
of the way
gets that tension out of the way like
you're being you're being told you're
creepy because you are being damn creepy
what do you guys think is the biggest
red flag in the opposite gender so in in
men what is the biggest red flag no
communication lack of communication so
if they don't text you no not
Communication in that sort of way like I
can go at all divertics and someone it
simply bother me but when I say
communication when it comes down to
things that matter okay like what
so
feelings for one maybe no not maybe
definitely okay so if they're not
telling you they like you I'm not saying
that they like me no but like for
example how can I put it
just just communication in general just
knowing where people are at if that
makes sense or for example I believe
relationships aren't 50 50. they I don't
I don't think that's a thing and I don't
think it ever has been a thing some days
relationships can be 80 20 or it could
be 40 60 but
it's the fact that you you in how can I
explain it
just in order just just general basic
communication like how was your day and
not just saying oh yeah I'm okay thanks
like actually getting in debt with it
who do you think communicates better men
or women
[Music]
men logically yeah men uh men are very
direct and forward and to the point
where women have the tendency to just
absolutely flap around like and they end
up going from men go from A to B it's
like a story start middle Finnish
whereas women go from here to here
and then they finally get to the just
after the end and then they've got to go
back to the middle one then they finally
get to the end and it's like
and I know it's been to it a lot women
do do a lot but like men some men just
find it
I think I find it difficult to
communicate like I'm like I just want to
know communicate what just how like not
even how they feel like about the
relationship or anything like that
wouldn't wouldn't that just mean it's
not into you yeah in a way yeah I get
that but no I mean just general
communication doesn't matter whether it
be with uh a partner in that sort of way
or whether it be do you find that
communicating more with women
solves problems or gives you more
problems depends on what you're
communicating about that is the question
it depends on what you're communicating
about who's involved in the conversation
and I need it please don't no no no it
depends I need you I need you to give me
one way or the other
um
[Laughter]
the real joke is that she said
communication is a red flag and
literally you just had a serious problem
communicating no I mean it's a red flag
like not not being able to communicate
he's a massive red flag like if you're
upset tell me why you're upset and we'll
work through it together like that's
what that's exactly what I'm just saying
yeah you're limiting yours to just in a
relationship and when it comes to sex
and feelings and all that but you can't
even communicate the point across now so
how would you even be able to
communicate in a relationship oh
sparingly probably yeah on a first date
red flag first date right flag oh if
they've got a bad breath or if they've
got like horrible teeth okay yeah that's
got to be a problem out here the teeth
is like oh the teens are known for like
I haven't noticed it too bad out here
crooked teeth I can deal with but like
see like or if they're like dirty and
grimy and
no I couldn't do it red flag well you
will you ghost or will you text them
that you're done with them I'm too nice
I have to text him you've got your text
I've just got along with it a little bit
what will you say in the text if you're
if you're done with the date there's the
crooked teeth you gotta go oh but it was
really nice meeting you like I'd see you
again soon probably not no and then
after that like so so you do ghosts like
yeah yeah
our biggest red flag
um I would say touching back on the
communication in dating
if you haven't like if we're dating I
expect you to check up on me I would say
every day
so if he's not checking up on you yeah
if you're not checking up on me
um you're airing my calls or you're not
responding to messages like it just
shows that you're not interested and
then you will come back and say oh wha
like why can't you come back and say oh
I'm working I'm busy
um I'll get back to you just having that
communication there just shows two
things either you're not interested or
yeah like it's it's a bad point so what
if what if he is interested and is there
anything he could do to make you not
interested
um so like it's going like he he's
showing that he's interested in you yeah
but this happened now you got a ghost
or or text to me it depends which way
you go
um having multiple girlfriends have
emotions as friends oh oh female friends
yes do you have male friends uh not
really you know not really so you do or
you don't
um I would say about I would say I have
how about for your four male friends
yeah I'm a sales girl okay I don't
really have male friends wait so you
have four male friends yeah but but okay
but
I have female friends no he can but uh
no more than so like a female best
friend that's a red flag okay but you
can have your four male friends
it's all right just be honest it's all
right all right so you
know you spend I know that you'll go
into your female best friend to come
find in her and tell her oh you can
fight in your male friends be honest
um for example if say okay say the guy
is not communicating with me so you guys
look at me very good question the guys
that communicating with me and he I
don't know he's not answering calls and
he's not replying to messages I might go
to my male friend and say oh is he
interested so you do okay all right all
right all right do you do you think your
male friends are attracted to you
no uh no
you don't think there's no guy they like
they like listening to your feelings so
so you think they think you're ugly
I've never I don't know uh no I wouldn't
think I think I'm ugly okay
I don't think they look at me like that
is do you have you ever heard the phrase
men will [__] anything
do you think that's true
[Laughter]
yes or no yes or no
um yeah yeah okay so you do think they
would want to sleep with you
[Laughter]
my comment
we can test it
yeah do you want you want to call him
now
wow wow
you could show them the show later and
show them that this isn't real but just
to see
I say what well and just just say you
know it's late I've been thinking why
haven't you and I gotten together
all right
now you can't you have to make them
think it's real I don't know how you
guys talk but you got to talk normal put
on speaker thank you
if they answer let's see
I knew your phone better not ring right
now fine
um
let me silence it
hope you didn't send a warning text
first I did it because you were typing
for really long no I was trying to think
of somebody
they'll answer
oh they're not answering
yeah
no my Signal's bad up here
oh get her the Wi-Fi we'll fix it don't
worry okay next clip next person
FaceTime audio Yeah Yeah get her get her
the Wi-Fi okay Romeo will get you the
Wi-Fi don't worry we got good service up
here you can come on Rome that's all
right
[Laughter]
how many so would you be comfortable if
he had four female friends that were
trying to sleep with him all the time
no no but there's just a bit of a double
stick it's okay it's okay or is this a
bit of a double standard the fool guys
that I would class with my friends
they're not my best friends okay there's
a degree it's just friends but you do
talk to them about him yeah like I might
go to advice here and there but I know
your best friend is someone who you
speak to me speak to continuously every
day okay we'll try it one more time for
fun
I'm here to have a good time you know
you put your sound on if they call back
feel free to answer okay all right what
about you red flag on a on a first date
we're talking about surface level red
flags has to be uh not taking care of
yourself so the way that would show up
on a first day would be drinking vaping
yeah those would be the obvious ones
okay and will you ghost after will you
send her a text like you're not
interested anymore
uh either one which one do you do more
I don't really go on dates but you know
you don't go on any dates not not has to
has to break a major barrier to even get
to that point so I'm not even risking
I'll never risk being on a date and then
finding out about the red flag you know
I mean I have to have a high level of
confidence even so you have to like be
friends with her first before you take
her on a date not to say friends will be
you know familiarized yeah you have to
like know her you wouldn't meet her off
an app or anything no no I mean you
could meet but it'd have to be like some
some investigations and some
interrogation you'll go through her IG
yeah whatever speak a good amount
understand yeah what is this person
about okay and no no ghost thing it's
like 50 50. yeah either one no no
Affinity to could be ghosts it could be
very straightforward and just let them
know Dimitri um back in the day well so
the again it's like how you meet the
person matters like for example today in
2023 I find that some women I'm seeing
the internet and appear some women have
penises that would be a very big red
flag uh an immediate disqualification
um but if I were to be honest like
because I can talk more honestly now
because like I have no skin in the game
it's just be if she's fat like that's
just like sorry but like you made a
critical error in your decision making
and I see you as a risk uh to any
potential anything period And I can go
much deeper into that but that's like a
that's a miscalculation on your part so
it's a no Okay so so but you wouldn't
know if she was fat before the date well
again I'm saying it's like the context
of what do I know because like like I
can see obviously like we can get
catfished into that so if you
misrepresented yourself uh that's like
you're immediately an untrustworthy
person what what was like a red flag on
a first date like it's going well and
then she but she did
um
my goodness man I mean how transparent I
mean again like there's you could list
them all go off like like the thing for
me is like transparently like I'm a
Salesman and I know like I am I am a
Salesman and like as the salesman my
goal is always to close and so when I
went on a date like uh transparently my
goal was to get laid and it was
specifically entirely to get laid and
everything I did and the way I optimized
my actions through another sounds like a
psychopath but the way that I optimize
my actions through a number of
iterations of dates was like I want to
get laid on this date right
um and and and again I'm gonna get like
super castigated for this in the
comments good great like I had gone on
enough dates because I started
approaching women and I started like hey
what's your name hey I thought you were
cute I want to say hi I'm not at the
level as these results guys now are but
I was very passionate about that because
I like to make myself uncomfortable and
cross the barrier into the new Comfort
zones right which is I'm a Salesman like
how did I make and how do I make money I
pick up the phone I cold call and I
learn to iterate optimize and then
transform time and energy into money
right
um and I became extremely proficient at
like like the meat and clothes like I'm
gonna meet you and you know within about
three hours because I'm gonna you know
this dilute time through taking you to
various venues whatever the that stuff
was at the time
that's what's gonna happen
um so I don't know if I could so it
maybe she stays the night but she did
something and made you not call her back
I'm asking like what would make you not
call a girl um I think I think I think
what happens is over time is if you are
successful that you start to notice some
pretty uh resounding patterns like if a
girl says I never do this it means she
always does it you know uh so if a girl
starts to give me signals of virtue that
I know she's actually covering for the
fact that she is promiscuous
um which is very I okay it is incredibly
um hypocritical of me to say that
obviously if I'm optimizing to get laid
and I'm saying well if you do it then
you're whatever and you're doing that
whatever right
um but yeah signals of non-purity and
non-chastity would be would be big one
of the things that I have some examples
other than that so if she says I never
do this what else yeah like like for
example look when you're in a contact
stuff a date like she absolutely knows
what's happening you're just trying to
make it you know seem like it's not
happening even though it's like it just
happened but you know it's clearly
happening
um you know if a woman exhibits more
masculine Behavior for example like it's
very clear that like a woman that makes
decisions and acts like a man is is more
promiscuous and science has actually
proven that and back that up as well
um but I'll say this one thing that
really attracted me uh to the woman that
became my wife is that it was very
apparent to me that she really wasn't
that experienced
um in being seduced like it was very
clear to me because and this is why this
is where I have a Divergence with a lot
of people that follow your channel
because I'm generally a pretty
conservative guy right but then guys and
then you would say well so you're saying
you should date to marry I'm like no as
a man you should date to get laid
because you want to learn about the
nature of women understand the patterns
of the exhibit and make yourself the
best version for the woman you'll
eventually marry and be dangerous and
have those options and a lot of guys you
can't say that you're just giving out
your body it's like no guys nobody wants
your body like you got to learn how for
a woman to actually to actually want you
like that's that's a really difficult
skill to learn and a worthy one
um but for me like if I can tell that
she's more promiscuous and you can tell
those patterns very quickly once you've
seen enough times obviously that's like
okay I can't escalate but I'll but I may
have kept her around for other means and
purposes right transparently tell them
about the one girl you dated well so she
was I mean I I got what I deserved she
was a stripper but I was I was young at
the time yeah
um and she was like just she actually
approached me it was at the W Hotel in
Dallas Texas I was living in Texas at
the time and there's a club and like I
think the sub Penthouse or Penthouse
floor in the Dow in the W Hotel and she
came up to me and we started talking I
was just like oh my God she's so hot and
she was like to me she was a 10. like
she just looked like I was like I was
blown away that she's talking to me and
then and then I find out she's a sports
fan we go to a sporting event there's
all these you know players on the on the
uh in the arena playing whatever they
Sport and and there's I think 10 10
players on it was a hockey game and she
had like gone through and she had slept
with eight of them no way dude
and then and then she started like this
was after a few months so we've been
like kind of seeing each other I was
young and then but but she was so hot
and sexually she helped me grow so much
because she was so sexually like she was
just like taking me on a ride I was like
this is I'm calling my friends guys this
is the greatest thing I've ever
experienced and it's amazing and she
owns a house I don't know how she owns a
house and it turns out I mean I was an
experience this is what made me wake up
I'm like I thought this was the greatest
trick ever it's like no she had she
owned a house in the early 20s because
she was a stripper yeah and then and
then it came out all the famous she
slashed me one time did you ever sleep
with anyone famous somebody at the time
I'm like no at that time I hadn't and
then she's like oh I should tell you I
was this guy then and then I realized
that for her she was one of those
groupie chugs that like her her
confidence grew because she was able to
get guys that other women couldn't
because these guys actually could reject
women right and then I'm like and I'm
like holy crap man like no wonder she's
blowing my mind sexual and I realized
right away I'm like oh I can't take her
seriously more but I was infatuated
because I just you know I I was in my
early 20s and when a woman that's that
hot that she can sleep with A-list
celebrities is giving you some you're
just like ah I'm living in a movie but
but obviously like no as a wife like
that that would be a terrible decision
did you ghost her or did you did you no
I never I would never ghost anyone ever
because and this is again this is
implicit to like my value system I I
really thought through my value system
for when I was growing up a lot like I
spent a lot of time by myself I wasn't
the most popular kid in high school and
when you're not popular and like and
that's actually one thing that I think
the society's missing we're missing some
freaking bullying man like like we're
like bullying is like you're like we
shouldn't believe you know bring back
bowling bro for real bring it back I was
bullied so much in school I think and I
deserved it you really do obey you know
I mean it makes you stronger no because
it sets the boundaries like bullying is
the truth it sets the boundaries on what
people appreciate and don't appreciate
right yeah like like I was a loser and
it's okay like people are like hey loser
blah blah and I'm like why aren't why
are they picking me it's like oh because
I don't physically defend myself because
I act in feminine ways to try to resolve
conflict when that's not the rules that
men need to abide by right and that
feedback helped me sit there and think
and and iterate in my mind like what
should I be doing to have better
outcomes in the way I'm getting it and
this is one of the things about your
channel so I've been on the show a
couple times right
and sometimes I peek in the comments to
see how what people say and here's
what's interesting and I find this
fascinating right when I say something
to the effect of women should be held
accountable and should hold themselves
accountable
all the guys are like Dimitri spitting
the facts brought the facts right the
moment I say that men need to hold
themselves accountable you're a simp
you're this you're that it's like
no man like like a little bullying guys
is not a bad thing because it helps you
be better like and you owe it to
yourself to make promises to yourself
that you keep and follow through on so
yes women should be more accountable
obviously but as men we should be
accountable too
yeah I I think though it's because the
world will show men the truth where
women will say lizzo's at 10 not you
guys yeah but but listen but but again
I'm sorry if I'm taking her like you cut
me off but like even yesterday like the
ques you you asked me a question like
should you know would your daughter
marry a bus driver I'm like hell no my
daughter's not gonna marry a bus driver
it's not going to happen like as her dad
I work way too damn hard I live in a too
nice neighborhood I sent her to a
freaking top like she goes to an
elementary school that has the word
College in it like when you're doing
that like I'm putting her you know I'm
putting her in classrooms with like kids
of ambassadors and and kids of the the
guy that runs the stock market in our
country is like that those kind of kids
right I'm doing it so she doesn't marry
a bus driver and this doesn't matter so
the men go and they're like oh you don't
like middle class working men that run
Society I'm like no that's not what I'm
saying I'm saying is I don't want my
daughter to marry a career bus driver
because that is not the problem that a
50 year old man should be solving on how
to drive the bus from point A to point B
by the time you're 50 you should be
running the damn organization and taking
care of other employees and growing in
your career that's the point yes there's
nothing wrong with electricians when
you're 26 27 years old but if you're
doing the same thing at 59 that you were
at 27 you're solving the wrong problems
right so that's where the accountability
argument comes in is that there there's
a a problem that you solve but it has to
be age-appropriate
what do you think red flag first state
um a woman that's like um always talking
about her ex does that has that happen
before
on a first date
but when you get to know it I'm going to
talk about the ex about the x is in
their life or not if I have a had a kid
or and they're talking about an ex I'm
saying hard there harder broke off and
things like that
yeah well you ghost or or you will you
send him a text and be like stop talking
about the X goodbye forever I feel like
for a minute it's not even ghosting
though because if you don't reach out
they're not even gonna you know I mean
it's not like ghosting it's like you're
just kind of choosing to end the
dialogue
really yeah women will never reach out
rare it's rare they have to be bold oh
do you know guys sorry about this but
real quick do you know what happens when
you don't go some you probably
experienced this when you're like Hey
listen you're really cool but I see that
you have some feelings and you're trying
to escalate the relationship I just want
to let you know that this is not going
to be a serious relationship for me and
you have to deal with it she just gets
more attracted to you and then she just
it's like it's like what are you doing I
literally just told you who I am why
have you found that to be true too if
you guys like put a girl in the the
Friends with Benefits though and she
wants you more yes yes
and if you find that if you try to
commit to her she wants you less yes yes
yeah what do you guys have to say about
that why do we do that
do you guys do you guys find that you
guys want guys you can't have it's not
it's interesting because that why why
don't you want me not on that why don't
you want to know why you want to know
why they don't want you
because yeah what if they said like
you're annoying
would you
then stop chasing
uh me personally I was I'll ask them why
how no no what I'm saying they say
you're annoying then what
it is end of the conversation I'll stop
that I just want to know why do you
think I'm annoying
[Music]
I dig too deep that's why
uh what made oh I have a question for
you you're engaged right what made your
fiance different than guys you dated in
the past
um he doesn't he doesn't go out
we're we're two completely different
people so he doesn't go out but I go out
a lot
as in Raven clubbing yeah wow then
Dynamics are crazy I'm a sociable person
I've always been at that like to
socialize
um as I said I'm a girls girl so yeah I
I'm out a lot
yes he doesn't like that so I tries to
minimize it but um I just don't think I
could be with someone that is also
outside as well you like you've got a
lot of doubles yeah that's crazy that's
crazy
that it wouldn't work it would be
you want him to go
to go
um
I just I just feel like any guys that I
kind of meet outside or in a party
environment
like just looking at them and how they
carry themselves and how they're moving
how they're approaching to females what
they're doing just doesn't appeal to me
can I ask a question so how do you move
when you're out it may no no
so so what if used to meet somebody
that's Reserve yeah move the same way
that you do out in a club
yeah like I would I would it would be an
option to speak to that I would oh yeah
I would talk to you or I would get to
try and get to know you but my
preference is I like
a guy that's so what would you do if
your current boyfriend says he wants you
to stop going out Charlie
[Laughter]
and I'm asking that because if he's
watching I'm giving him ideas
Bravo
like we have a lot that's Mo we don't
argue a lot but most of the arguments
are about you know you're going out too
much
but when you met me I was going out too
much yes I understand that in
relationships you should change certain
things you know like if your partner
doesn't agree on certain things you
should work and
work around it and compromise which I
have and I've actually
don't go out as much as I used to I
would say I go out probably
a lot
yeah how would you how would you feel if
your boyfriend went out to a party where
every single girl he met wanted to sleep
with him
then
that yeah that was that's crazy
that would hurt me but I didn't remember
earlier when we said men will [__]
anything
gotcha
it's true yeah I can't say anything
about that but yeah he um yeah he
doesn't go out
um he doesn't his phone barely Rings
like he goes to work he's an electrician
so he goes to work he comes home we have
a daughter together as well
he's a good man he sounds very safe yeah
he's like I have I've never had any
problems like his phone doesn't even
have a password like it's not what do
you think the role of a wife is
um a role of a wife
um I would say to look after the
household
and obviously to raise the children in
the right way and to cater to your man
like to cater to him make sure his
um work clothes are washed make sure his
he's got a hot meal and his
um on the table when he comes home from
work but I wouldn't say that sorry that
is what I think yeah I yeah I don't do
that oh tomorrow
I don't do that every day
what so women no no I meant to cook for
their husband every day is that so
what's your question
catering to your man be like listening
to what he says
do you believe that wives should listen
to their husbands
yeah okay so if we told you you just now
okay listen
Pub
very very uh what's it called um
so no you know there's a that's Star
Wars saying like he could pity it's what
is it ironic he could solve him save
himself from dying no he could save
others from dying but not himself Darth
Sidious there's like ironic he could fix
short circuits but not his own
I have a question though if if you're if
your man was like doing his duties
towards you like providing for you and
like being there for you emotionally
only like
a couple of days in a week
like he just he was lackadaistical about
it sometimes you'll be there for you
sometimes it just messes around would
you stay
yeah you won't right
okay that's interesting but I don't mess
around no I know I'm not I'm giving the
equivalent because what men and women
bring to each other are different we
don't bring the same things okay so on
his end if he wasn't holding up to his
duties yeah most more than likely you
replace him yeah and I would say that
would be fair so that being said do you
think it will be do you think it's
possible that he he could probably find
someone
that would bring more to the table for
him and that could turn his head yeah
100 and you're willing to take that risk
by continuing to
go out the only issue is is me going out
shouldn't be an issue is the kit is the
kid is the kid biologically his
what no you said you guys have a kid
together yeah is it his kid oh yeah so I
hope you went and I stepped I'm I'm
asking I don't know like I don't know
the nature of the relationship right
yeah
so when I got pregnant is when I got
engaged
oh okay
and she's two now
do you have any plans to stop growing up
anytime soon do you know what it's just
my part it's just me like this is what I
I like I like I like God when I say like
okay I like going to day parties I like
going out with my girls like I like
going having a games like with my girls
or movie night like I I like that what
if he gave you an ultimatum and said
it's either the girls or him who would
you pick and not I would definitely pick
him okay so you would give it up if you
made it an ultimatum yeah so if he put
his foot down then you would actually
but I don't think I would be happier as
a person
do you think happiness is a choice
gotcha
[Laughter]
um yeah okay so so then you could be
happy hang on and you still ask other
guys for advice when there's something
up in your relationship
um not always so no not always but and
then say no do you still sometimes like
hey give me some advice on the fiance
but immigrant yeah that's sometimes so
in the dating period yeah with him in
the Dyson period I was asking for advice
but now
we've been together for
nearly five years now so these and these
guys are still in your phone and they're
still like talking to you from time to
time Etc yeah
you're done when I go out I'm curious
look on the marriage like what's the all
you gotta do is go down to the
courthouse uh so when I got engaged was
2021 I said I wanted to wait till my
daughter turns five so she can remember
or have a bit of a memory of
why is this my preference oh okay it
just it seems like a silver enough to
just see it just say it you're not that
into him listen when a woman really
loves a man she can't wait to escalate
the commitment she wants to shout it
from the rooftop she wants everyone to
know she's running to the altar like
this is not this is not how women in
love act it's not that I'm not no
because if I wasn't that into him I
wouldn't be having a baby for him and I
wouldn't accept uh marriage proposal you
wouldn't be going out and like partying
with the girls and having arguments
about it that's crazy about me as a
person yeah I'm not it's how it comes
across though I'm not saying that's what
it is I'm just telling you how it comes
across
but if if he didn't like that that's
what he saw when he first met me so yes
we qubble about it because it's the
amount of going out or whatever but it's
not the going out it's just that amount
who's watching the kid when you go out
oh so I have a big support system like
my mom my grandmother and his grandma
his mom him don't you think that's kind
of like putting your responsibility on
to them no so I also sell hair as well
so use the in the evenings like his Mum
would watch my daughter my mom would
watch so I could go and do my deliveries
or do what I'm doing
um but I have like throughout the week
like I have like set schedules and when
she goes so I would just work in between
that if I want to go out that I'll work
in between that schedule
that's so crazy to me guys I'm sorry
would you guys like I want to actually
if I can ask the dudes here would you
guys accept that in your marriage oh no
no no really no way
only forgotiable I could go out together
then it's different but at least one
person coming out and I'm staying
snapping it no marketing this is that's
insane like I actually to me I'm like
I'm like flabbergasted like this is
insane to me and maybe I'm the crazy one
right because the reality is not making
sense hmm
I I see because with most of my friends
in relationships and they're doing the
same thing did you see your grandmothers
do this no did you see your mom do this
yeah the moms are kind of where it
switches grandmother know right no it's
kind of the degradation of wives the
last hundred years to be honest like
there's a like our mom's generation
they're kind of the shitty wives a lot
of and it shows up in the data most of
them are divorced you can't really learn
much from our mom's generation like the
40 to like 55 year olds they're just
kind of bad wives to be honest the the
grandma Yeah I mean how many like so do
you believe that you can't be a good
wife and go out yeah no I I don't think
it goes hand in hand I think yeah I
think you know occasionally sure but not
to a club like I I don't who wants to
grow up with a mom that's in the club
every other weekend
the reality is I I like noticing Trends
in society yeah the reality is there's a
trend going on and I think let me use
the word women like to use a lot
Spectrum there's something there's
something of a spectrum going on at the
lower end of the spectrum you have women
that want to be the men and do whatever
they want go out while the men become
the nurturing Partners on the other end
of the spectrum you have the Adam 22
situation so it starts from that first
part and usually it keeps going and
going out and the woman finds different
ways to violate the man till he gets to
the point where she can then even ask
for an open relationship or she can ask
to sleep with another man on camera
that's how it starts it's like it's just
a spectrum basically
like the thing about the thing about
again I'm speaking from a position of
being 40 and being married and have lots
of friends I don't know I don't have any
friends that are divorced all my friends
are are very successful and definitely
married with kids it's like
um commitment doesn't doesn't like if
you look at the color of commitment it's
not gray
it's just not like commitment is very
black and white and if it doesn't look
like commitment is just not and it's and
and you know and you see these patterns
like King you were saying in society you
see it on the micro level as well right
like the guys that had those situations
and whenever age like well I don't I'm
not really in their spheres anymore like
because they just kind of their lives
just get wrecked and they kind of go
into like repeat mode because a woman
has generally just ruined their life uh
yeah this smells a lot like that sorry
it just does
well it's kind of like it kind of just
disrupts the natural like order of
things because you're supposed to obey
your husband
and so it's like if you're going out and
he doesn't want you to it's just kind of
out of order
so if you're going out but you're also
doing everything else that he wants you
to do do you still think that that's a
problem yeah I would say it's a problem
it's a big problem yeah and I'm not
saying every person's gonna do it
perfectly but I I think that
it's not good if we're having wives and
mothers go out instead of staying at
home with the kids you disagree no I
agree yeah I do sorry yeah I do um
yeah I do I don't know like my mum's so
my mum my mom's 40. growing up
she used to go out a lot
um I yeah I don't know I don't know if
she's still married yeah she's married
and your dad had no problem with her
like going out uh she's not married to
my dad but she's married to my little
brother's Dad okay yeah uh no
um because so I went to school in
Jamaica
um so growing up in Jamaica
the school bus to school we would like
it was crazy like we would be listening
to music on the way to school dancing on
the school bus on the way to school on
the weekends as a young child they had
Street parties as well so we'll be out
like I don't know I feel like that's my
culture that's what I'm going into like
from Young I was going to Carnival with
my family with my parents how old are
you again I'm 25. okay your mom had you
at 15. yeah so you have to say this I
think it's a discrepancy of values right
because even what you just explained
shows that for you it feels like
something that's normal right but it's a
values thing like for me going to the
club is Extreme activity like that's
super on the end of the spectrum that
King was saying extreme but if it feels
normal for you that's why you kind of
have a hard time seeing it as something
that's bad or odd because it's just a
normal thing it feels casual and as I
said again like everybody around me not
saying that I follow fashion or follow
everyone around me but my whole um
society and the community that I grew up
in and my friends you said your grandma
did do it though right no not my grandma
but that's what I mean it's it's a I I
don't think it's like your culture I
think it's the culture
like a Decor day like because if it was
the culture then your grandma would have
been doing the same thing it's fairly
new Western
yeah were there even clubs in that time
not really right no that's that's the
point it's like like literally when I
had the realization I'm like 40 to 55
year old women do not submit to like in
general and there's exceptions but they
don't really submit to their husband
most of them are divorced most of the
guys that are still married aren't
really happy in that marriage like
there's just a lot of shitty wives in
that generation and they don't they
didn't teach us right because like I
mean honestly the fact that you're
surprised by this is like kind of shows
the culture hmm
it's a like support when you go out like
a street party as you said it's a street
point or like go outside you could be
outside your house and there's a party
have sound system listen to music the
brother sister my Uncle Auntie so it's
like it is kind of different but of
course with generational but it's a new
thing though right would you say your
grandma did that too no yeah that's what
I'm saying it's like a new it's it's a
new cultural Trend and it's across the
board like I don't think it's just in
Jamaica like I think there's women in
England that do the same thing but then
again what you're describing sounds more
like a you know Community neighborhood
like you know you're just in the
neighborhood in a you know suburban area
hanging out that's probably different
than like a nightclub in England you
know what I mean yeah that sounds like a
little more family oriented yeah so
that's like that's how I grew up so
so
like the street parties in my
neighborhood in Jamaica yeah my family
would be there not my grandma but my
auntie is your family going to the club
with you
uh no but I was I could see my
you know it's in England you know what's
interesting it's your aunties not your
uncles
no right yeah because the women are out
of order
[Laughter]
I've just done these so many times it's
always the women yeah
um okay wait I have a soup two super
chats they're a hundred dollars so I'm
gonna read them now these are not my
opinions they're the opinions of the
chat I'm sorry if you get roasted
um
um okay guys also make sure you like the
video and subscribe to the channel
because that is what YouTube uses to
push out these live streams especially
the like button I'm actually going to go
through all of them just gonna go
through the first two uh Thane Matra is
back and he says tradcon women and men
keep relationships private and work on
issues behind closed doors kids are
never supposed to be privy to
relationship Strife then matcha you
can't wife an alley cat she's for the
streets
um fat Fark um we love you Pearl you my
world 2004 Pearl you were doing a
documentary on the court system how
about introducing some International
flavor please enjoy interview
depika bahaja something I'm sorry guys I
can't pronounce names just my lot life
um MRI um if I don't know DM heard of me
I guess uh kithali Swiss in regards to
the title it's because there's nothing
they can do to change men and it's even
harder for women to find the drive for
self-improvement so they resort to sign
language I'm gonna refresh it really
quick just to make sure I didn't
forget anything okay red flag I don't
think you went right okay
um on the First Dates yeah
what if she says I'm gonna go to the
club throughout our relationship
I thought that was that was my my
younger wild Foods in my life no
um Now red flags would be
um
good question
somebody that's just not ambitious
it has to be
very ambitious
um you want your woman to be ambitious
yeah what do you want her to be
ambitious about just uh have like some
type of self-drive just I want to do
things like to be productive and even if
she hasn't got like a specific thing
just like the want to go and learn or
you know so positive yeah positive
positive yeah positive habits so a
lawyer red flag or green frat flag no
that's a big green flag that's a green
flag she's a lawyer I think that's like
the biggest red flag I would tell I
would tell men to avoid lawyers at all
costs really oh yeah they're just like
feminists that argue for a living no I'm
not I'm not a few few layers
and not really argumentative but if if
an argument breaks out though you know
yeah yeah right in 2023 a lawyer really
yeah it's true maybe you got me
[Laughter]
um yeah and they just indoctrinate them
oh my gosh no you cannot do a lawyer I'm
telling you because they teach them all
the abuse languages so they'll be like
you'll they'll be like your coercive
controlling me
it
hm all this like feminist stuff
um
will you ghost
yeah your ghost if you don't find her
ambitious what if she just says she
wants to start a family and she has no
she doesn't want to work ever
at Flagler green flag yeah that's a big
red flag it's a red flag she just wants
to stop yeah she says I want to be a
wife and a mother I want to have your
babies
oh
I don't know
um no I don't think I could still do
that you know she's gone yeah I think
she's gone like I I want a woman that's
got that's got something she has to be
able to there has to be something there
you know that you have to have some type
of Drive some type of ambition Pearl
wouldn't you say though that that type
of boldness is a little bit masculine
which one saying like this is what I
want I want wife kids well okay maybe
not on the first date but no not that
early but you know me being that forward
of I know what I want this is what I
want I want this from you no I don't
I mean I don't know how you would say it
maybe not in that way but like the women
that I know that got married young that
were really traditional like they were
all pretty clear that they wanted to be
a wife and a mother early like they
weren't trying to waste their time but I
feel like they didn't have to like push
for it as like hey this is what I want
if it was a little more just kind of
natural you know what I mean
um I mean I'm I don't know I don't know
how they said it I just know they
their time with any guy that like didn't
want to get married
what do you think about that Dimitri I
learn a lot like I learn a lot about
women from my wife because she's you
know we're 40 so there's a little bit of
self-reflection so I think that brings a
little bit of wisdom my wife said
something a couple weeks ago that really
made me think a lot as we were just kind
of hanging out and she's like I'm so
glad that I don't like have to go out
like we can just sit here and like watch
a show
maybe because we were sitting watching a
show and I was like
do you ever miss going out no you were
22. she's beautiful you were beautiful
you know you were going out she's like I
don't miss going out at all the pressure
of it I'm like I know this was coming
from a 40 year old woman so there's some
some looking back at what pressure she
goes do you know how hard it is when
you're 23 and you're going out to
parties trying to find somebody that
could be your husband and I'm like I'm
like you were going to parties trying to
find somebody to be your husband she's
like why else would I be going crazy and
I was like and I was just like real I I
was like wow that's a crazy like that
might be a little bit of retrospective
like you know uh like fairy dust
whatever but I I just then like really
that's why he went out she's like why
else would I be going clubbing like of
course like I'm there to to meet a guy
that's the right guy or I'm gonna go to
a party or however else it was right I
thought it was kind of nuts I'm until
he's mad yeah
Vance says very few career women leave
masculinity at the door of the home and
respect the man is the head of the
household this is why there is a rise of
stay-at-home dads what do you guys think
of that stay-at-home dads
Long Peak a woman's job it's a woman's
job
yeah it is a women's job to stay at home
and look after the house look after the
children and
like at the end of the day like I've not
had kids but I know when if if I do have
kids and if I do it's a big if I don't
really want children to be honest but um
you don't like kids
um
I do and I don't I just look at society
today and I think what the
so so I wouldn't give you more
motivation to raise good kids
yeah but fix it and it's not like like I
I wouldn't just have a child with just
anyone like I'd have to leave anyone
like the right guy yeah the right guy it
might be a bit different story but I
don't think I've really met him yet so
yeah I have to cross that bridge when I
come to it yeah you've never have you
ever had like a long-term relationship
yeah what was what was wrong with him I
really hope he's not watching this
um yeah what was wrong with him
we just grew apart really what was wrong
with him he was a narcissist
um yeah he was a major narcissist major
narcissist what did he do to be that was
a narcissistic
what what was narcissistic yeah like
what did he do like it's like because I
would imagine if he's a narcissist he
must have been doing crazy stuff like I
wouldn't say he's what you would call a
stereotypical narcissist he's a special
nurse he's not like a direct narcissist
24 7 that would sit there and beat you
down to a pulpey he wouldn't do that
that bit if you come across more like
patronizing if that makes sense like
belittling actually I gotta be honest
beating someone to a pop is not
narcissism though
yeah but that that's that's not that's
not what narcissism means no not sitting
there let me get the words out
narcissism is when you don't really care
about anyone but yourself and towards
the end at the first start of the
relationship no I would say I didn't see
that I didn't see that at all but then
when you start getting like six months
down the line or a year down the line
and and you start seeing sides of
someone that you thought you know but
are completely different okay like what
so for example
he has like I went to University quite a
lot
and for me that was a big step in my
life and
it's just like I don't know like it was
just never happy for me or save our
probably probably not the best examples
we're talking about like say if I went
out for my friends for one of my friends
birthdays but at the time obviously I
look at it a little bit differently now
but at the time yeah I would see him as
a massive narcissist because he wouldn't
he wouldn't let me go for a dinner with
my friends for example oh but this is
like and he didn't like my parents okay
but this is like all small like this is
a crazy big thing because it's really
horrible I just don't know why like
women women just call everybody a nurse
assistant
maybe you've just done so many right so
if it's one percent of us it's one
percent of the population is a
narcissist so it's unlikely that you
would even meet a narcissist much less a
date and so so the odds of you actually
dating a narcissist is like slim yeah so
I'd imagine if you're calling him a
narcissist there's like a diagnosis yes
which I don't I don't he had a
professional diagnosis no no okay okay
so then I would imagine there was like
some crazy things yeah but now it's like
he didn't want me to go to dinner with
my friends yeah he didn't really like my
parents no he wasn't happy for me no I
mean but I've had I sound like a
narcissist
towards the end of the relationship some
something really quite drastic happened
and obviously it's not really nice to
talk about it's not a nice situation for
anyone to go to especially any female
yeah that makes sort of sense no no he
didn't cheat but um I needed him there
when it was probably the most important
time in both of our relationships
together not just in on an individual
basis did someone die no no so
not to that extent no but so I've
basically I found out I was pregnant
with him obviously I told him and then
we were in our relationship for about
two years two and a half years at this
point and that's it
we had a rail and I just said I don't
want to talk to you right now and you
think I didn't hear from him about four
months five months oh he ghosted
completely blocked me off did you were
you on birth control yeah okay so he
probably felt deceived
that's probably what he like I'm telling
you guys point of view no problem so I
don't think that's a narcissist I think
he was just like this [__] told me she
was on birth control no no offense you
seem actually very nice I use [__]
sometimes I think you're worse than that
yeah
but you see what I'm saying yeah this
just doesn't scream like narcissist to
me and and it was very boring as well
girl no he was he was so boring and
narcissism usually boring not the age
story sounds true it sounds so pathetic
doesn't it it's so bad it's absolutely
shocking no but I think sometimes as
women we tell stories and we don't even
know how they no of course women we're
all biased to believe I think us as
individuals anyone anyone man men and
women are biased to believe their own
stories but women especially will tell
themselves a story to try and make
themselves feel a little bit better
about the situation and realistically
I've just had so many chicks say they
dated narcissists and I'm like it's one
percent of the population you can't have
all dated maybe not narcissist directly
then but maybe they would have shown or
portrayed narcissistic behavior
throughout do you think you ever have
narcissistic oh without a doubt are you
a narcissist I wouldn't say I'm directly
a narcissism
very narcissistic Tendencies sometimes
and I'll put my hands up all right all
right who is more narcissistic men or
women give me a context what's more
narcissistic social media or video games
that's where it comes in really like it
neither are a problem until they become
a problem and they're used in itself
okay okay but no no answer the question
what's more narcissistic
probably social media what's your what's
your screen time
should we have a look I don't even have
a look this is gonna make sick it's all
right it's all right okay you won't be
the place you won't be the light I use
this phone for work as well not not
trying to make myself how do you find it
what's the Instagram time you know what
I mean how'd you find screens yeah
settings
should be there then what average the
average ticket's like six or seven hours
a day
that's probably like on social media did
you see
11 hours a day
there's a Dev and I was to die yeah this
is my work phone as well so
so statistic
to be honest
probably me to be honest yeah yeah
because because you know instead of like
thinking of where he was coming from
when he ghosted you you were like oh he
wasn't there for me so it's like a me me
me mentality oh definitely but if you're
on like birth because he just probably
thought right it was a guy isn't that
what you would think if she was on birth
control then she got pregnant
you may have been but I'm just telling
you how it looks to like because if
we're on a birth control that's 98 99
effective we can only get pregnant three
days of the month so if you get pregnant
it's like the guys are kind of like ah
how did this happen
it's true I know someone else personally
that's it's the same situations happen
to them they're on the pill and they've
had two children from being on the pill
yeah yeah I I think you you seem very
nice but I think most women lie about
this [__] I think they get pregnant on
purpose I just don't believe it oh no I
just don't believe it it's it's really
not that hard not to get pregnant like
no I agree really like you can only get
pregnant three maybe five days of the
month
no I completely I don't completely agree
with you how are we all how are we all
getting pregnant left and right I just
don't get it I have a theory I think a
lot of women have
secretly unknowingly bipolar a bipolar
disorder where they have someone else
that commits crimes on their behalf
I think I think a lot of women have a
representative that commits crimes on
their behalf and then they can claim to
not know what happened I'm with you
exactly
allergies to accountability and
responsibility you know that's fine you
know it's funny I saw there's um a guy
from the 1900s talking about I was
reading about the court system in the
1900s and he was talking about how
female versus male victims even in the
early 1900s before social media women
would never admit they were guilty like
if a man committed a crime he might be
like all right I did it like I was wrong
I did it but the woman would always have
someone to blame and he was literally
talking about this in the 1900s so it
was someone else's fault always someone
else even if the action came down to the
person yeah no accountability but it's
interesting if if you say like um there
was another case where a guy um killed
his family and the reason he killed his
family was because the wife basically
threatened to like take all his [__] he
she threatened to leave him with the
kids like just financially ruin him and
it's like if we bring that up
there's no sympathy for the man but it's
it's like interesting because the other
way around if you say oh well she killed
her her baby but she was depressed but
she was this but she was that there's
like always Sympathy for the woman
there's never for the man
then the blame would go on mental
illness
yeah it's not it's not even up to her
just yeah she was just mentally yeah
um
yeah so so
you still you don't want kids though
with the right person possibly but
not as much not right this very second
no I'm never gonna say never because I
don't know what's going to happen
tomorrow I don't know what's going to
happen next week did you want kids
before no like when you were younger you
never have wanted kids no like even when
I was young like I've always been a
little bit of a girly girl but my mum
and dad used to buy me dollies they just
want me prams I'm gonna touch it when
did you get on social media
oh God I started with Tumblr okay Tumblr
oh God
about 13 maybe I think I think that
programs women to not want children
they're 12 13. think about it like
that's if you're at 11 hours now you've
probably been similar for a long time so
think about how much influence that has
over you every single day that's true
and all of the programming and the
messaging is like don't have kids don't
have kids kids are a burden
um you say that a lot of might like I
watch a lot of stuff to do with kids my
algorithm is full of kids go on Tick
Tock go on Instagram I've got all kids
doing this and that and blah blah blah
blah blah but I don't know it's it's
just modern society today and I think
it's absolutely shambolic and the dating
poll that like you said earlier like if
we were to go on Tinder or hinge or
anything like that the dating pool is
the same sort of men and what sort of
band like the men that
women would always go for like not per
se you would be
attracted them on a sort of mental level
like a mental capacity sort of level
it'd be more of a physical attraction
and
that's
I've lost my train of fault what's the
question what characters do you think
what character traits do you look for in
a boyfriend
what like surface level or just actual
just character traits five top five top
five uh caring
okay
um
has a good relationship with their
parents or like any adult figure in
their life has got respect for their
adult figures in their life because that
plays a big part in it
um
ambition
caring as the sea has good relationships
in each ambition is an a we've got
charts so the last one has to start with
the D chat yeah
despite despises modern so there it is
we got to spell Chad we're almost there
my number one is doesn't think women
should vote
um yeah wait really no not number one
but I agree with you on that like women
we just spell Chad no yeah
has a good relationship ambitious
doesn't chat
you think women shouldn't vote too no
women should vote women women have I'm
always alone women should vote women
everyone should be able to vote anyone
that is of a legal age should be able to
vote what about like what about like
idiots
you can have male idiots as well yeah
yeah I mean what about the male idiots
can they not vote anyone everyone should
have their right to vote I believe
should the criminals get to vote
absolutely yes yeah absolutely yes yes
they should and that's very simple it's
just this is like more of a
philosophical and like governmental
argument but it's because it prevents uh
because if criminals couldn't vote you
would have uh a surplus of government
power concentrated where people would be
appointed as criminals so that they
would not have the ability to vote right
so if you look at like most
constitutional monarchies today
criminals can vote judges cannot because
then you don't want judges to be able to
be bought for their votes right because
then they can take political decisions
in court and what you want to avoid is
political decisions in court you don't
want to say he's a criminal if you have
the authority to say that to him in the
U.S criminals campaign I was raised in
the Canadian constitutional monarchy and
I and I very much agree that even though
like I don't support criminals and
nobody likes criminals whatever yeah but
we can't give bigly on the Soviet Union
which is where you spend the first nine
years of my life a lot of people were
deemed thought criminals and immediately
you know they're removed from sort of
the the oh I see because the government
the government right right abuses the
power right so there by putting them
exactly so so you can't you can't take
away a person's you can't second class
as soon as another example would be the
code I can't say that word well in the
in the U.S you should just be Property
Owners remember remember when you when
you had to be waxed to get a job or or
to get on a bus or to go to a restaurant
Etc et cetera yeah those people that's a
second class thing because they said
well you're a criminal against Society
because you're creating an excess risk
of society which would turn out to be
untrue and completely manipulative but
that's where we run into that sort of
issue yeah well in the USA used to just
be landowners most people couldn't vote
until like the early 1900s late 1800s
like it was literally just landowners
yep wait we had it set up but democracy
is the worst like the best of the world
like there's no there's no good thing
right like you just it is what it is
what do you mean well I mean like
constitutional monarchies like the UAE
are amazing and wonderful but there's
also like a lot of not constitutional
markets I'm talking about like actual
like let's say benevolent dictatorships
there's a constitutional monarchies like
Canada but like
benevolent dictatorships like the UE are
amazing because they have amazing
leadership that invests in
infrastructure and people it's like it's
one of the greatest places on Earth
right but benevolent dictatorships
always have that risk of flipping to not
being so benevolent and then you turn
into a Venezuela situation right so so
in one second but but on the other end
democracy you kind of get you kind of
get a mix of everything so there's no
like good outcome that you can guarantee
under any system right yeah well but the
thing is is like usually you have to
have some skin in the game that's like
the way the US was for most of History
like it was you had to be a landowner
right and that way you could vote so
most men and women couldn't vote listen
I leaned towards benevolent dictatorship
myself like I just do um it's just
because because I I prefer like if I'm
in a company like and I am a CEO of a
company just so it turns out like I
believe that like I am better at making
decisions than most of the people that
are lower in that in that let's say
hierarchy chain and the reason is
because you know companies are built by
the market voting free with their
dollars meaning that you make enough
good decisions you can build something
substantive right and like for example
we have somebody that comes and helps us
clean our office like very nice lady
that does it but her decisions would not
be wise in the course of of like
choosing direction right whereas like in
democracy you know what you have is
usually a very unqualified person being
flipped for the next very unqualified
person and so it's not a good system but
it's the best system that we have right
what do you what do you think is your
biggest frustration with the dating
Market today
um
it's quite a good question
oh that is a really good question
they don't like to chase
anymore so man I feel like men don't
like to chase as much as they used to
you're engaged do you think do you think
yeah but I still have girlfriends female
do you think are you are your friends
worth chasing hmm
yeah
Tom then why aren't they being chased
I just it's the same common thing that
comes up around my friendship group and
my girls when I'm talking to my girls is
the same constant oh they're not chasing
they're not they're not doing enough if
a man's not getting laid would you would
you say it's the girls or is there
something wrong with him
all the girls are rejecting a guy yeah
is it is it the girls or is it him
him so so if the girls aren't getting
chased isn't that their fault isn't it
probably something wrong with them
I just felt like I feel like
nowadays maybe the guys in
well the guys that I know well in the
society or the guys at my friends date
they're just more they would want the
girls to rather chase them
then them do the chasing well maybe it's
because women don't respond well when we
Chase or when we when they chase us like
they were saying earlier how when they
reject us we want them more yeah that's
true so isn't it kind of our fault
because they respond to the market yeah
[Laughter]
um anything else any other frustrations
that you see with your friends
no
a lot of my friends prefer guys that
spend money
more so they would more gravitate
towards the guy that wants to maybe show
them a nice time or
is more like oh instead of going on a
normal date like let's go on holiday and
stuff like that they just wait they'll
take them on a trip instead of a date oh
boy where do they are they in
relationships with these guys or like
they're just dating who are they are
they celebrities
are they Bankers like what are these
high value men yeah no I'm asking like
what type of guys they date
um pimps
yeah high quality man what high quality
man okay no but like what what
industries are they dating
um like what I'm just trying to get an
architect okay so I have I have it's a
different so I have like
my friends that date guys that work in
finance like business guys or have their
own businesses or and then I have guys
girls that would date guys that are
footballers rappers and that's just how
I really remember okay yeah who's the
biggest rapper or footballer that slid
into your friend's DMs
I don't know no no one
she knows she knows
you know guys like if you're watching
this man like if your fiance or wife has
friends like that like run away run and
like don't look back just run just like
run like and don't even look just go
just as fast as you can that's insane
why because if that's your friend group
like dude like no like I mean you can
really really tell about a lot about a
person from their friend group and their
values and everything else like but
remember my well we're they're young so
they're ranging my girl why you have a
kid you have a kid man you got a kid and
and like you're engaged and you're
engaging like with these women even as
friends so my friendship group that I've
grown up with from college or uni
because of their type of men that they
attract or they go for right I shouldn't
be I shouldn't speak to them because I
am no you can speak to whatever you want
but your fiance should run for his life
why is my fiance running for his life
when well well I'm not doing I'm not
dating I'm not I'm not going with them
on Double Days listen I think his point
is you become who you surround yourself
with listen if my friends if a guy hangs
out with four losers he's gonna become
the fifth yeah if I'm not a gangster but
like all my friends are like in gangs
are getting popped off and like you know
doing drive-by shootings and everything
those are my friends it's like it's like
that's a pretty serious flag the best
saying that I yes I'm willing to cheat
yes it's exactly that's that's exactly
what it's saying there's there's numbers
that back this stuff up like one of the
one of the number one indicators that a
woman will get divorced is if her
friends start getting divorced
women women are very susceptible to what
the group does we are very influenced by
Propaganda it's why we all are with the
latest fashion trends that the men don't
even like it's why we got like caked
caked on makeup like all the like like
the bow top you know what I mean like
that look that every girl goes for like
the men don't even like it but it's
because we are very influenced by what
other women do well I've I'm the only
female in my friendship group and my
friends and my surroundings that is
engaged well and has a baby yeah and my
I would say that my well my friends they
have good jobs some work in Banks some
work in fact like they have good jobs
they're they're wholesome people they've
been to UNI they've studied they've got
their career like some have businesses
so but it says something about their
values if they're getting flown out by
the top 10 percent of men every every
other weekend or even if it's once a
month whatever it is like you're taking
trips with these rappers Ballers like
this is what you said so and I'm not
saying like you do it but I'm saying
like if you surround yourself by people
that do it like you're in general you're
more likely to do it
and so but I wouldn't know so I'm not
talking about you though okay
yeah I'm saying in general yeah but
women of course they're gonna say I it's
like asking a survey would you ever
cheat on your spouse no of course not
it's like no it doesn't work that way
like everybody's gonna virtue signal
positively the issue is that women
market right and if you're putting
yourself in positions where you're still
marketing and your friends are actively
marketing like there's a certain
correlation there but I mean it's I
think it's very obvious to men it's like
guys I mean I'm sure this has been said
a million times like you're never ever
gonna please a woman like who has been
flown out to like Dubai on dates like
what experience are you gonna provide
for her that's gonna make you her leader
like it's like yeah hey you want to go
down like and have a quick coffee it's
like yeah sure but in her mind she's
like I just got flown to Dubai and it's
like you lose you can't win well and
guys will even say that with like
lifestyle too like if a one woman starts
getting a certain lifestyle from a guy
another girl will wonder why she's not
getting that lifestyle and then start
like complaining like ring size like
whatever it is women we're just very and
it's actually really sad when you look
at the at the data of like how
influenced we are by the group but you
see the reality is this is this is one
of the serious problems of society
because this is really why a lot of men
like to protect the women that they hold
close to them because one you have to
protect your woman from physical Danger
you have to protect your woman from
other women and you also have to protect
your woman from herself because a lot of
women think that they they know how to
make these decisions they are the boss
babe but at the end of the day if you
look at the results it's the results
that matter why is everyone's why are
all the women in the west all tending
towards the same direction while you are
having the same results even though you
are all special and all different it's
because when a woman decides that she
wants to lead her relationship and she
wants to lead like you said you still go
and ask
um for advice from your male friend he
really only just takes one time for you
to really really hate your partner it
really just takes one time for him to do
something and then you're like nah and
you're out there and then before you
know it there's alcohol and then you're
going to come back and you're going to
start having these excuses that's that
most people that cheat that's that's how
it happens they never intended to go out
to do whatever so King on that I wanna I
wanna rip off you for a second that's
actually a conversation I had with my
wife because you know when you're
married you have to like discuss certain
expectations I actually
told her like what my definition of
cheating is because I want to be I want
to know exactly what is going on in our
relationship like that's really again
this is going back some time right my
exact definition was the moment you
complained to another man about anything
to do with our relationship it's it's
the moment that's that's the line for me
if you complain to another man about me
as a husband me as a father anything the
moment you complain about another man
and that right there that is the line
that I Define cheating right there
that's the line and what you're saying
is true and actually to your point as
well again kind of interesting you're
like women do what's popular it's like
something like one in three uh one in
three high school girls now identify in
some form of lgbtq it's like you wonder
right like so many women are identifying
with the most popular and the most Brave
uh and stunning group it's like hmm I
wonder what they're really identifying
right yeah you can convince us a damn
near anything honestly like the more I
look at like numbers I'm like you could
literally convince us that the moon is
made of
if the propaganda was good enough and we
said you're hip cool and brave for
believing that the moon is made of
cheese I swear to God I look at this
stuff and I'm just like I don't know how
we got here one in five women identify
as that like that's crazy it's more than
that for women it's like 20 of all youth
but it's higher for women right this is
nuts but it's popular going back to what
Dimitri was getting I think he was
saying in terms of the friend stuff that
if you're on such a different chapter
than your friends
that's kind of why you would assume that
your values and kind of your lifestyle
would be so drastically different that
you have less in common to where you're
not going to be spending too much time
with them even yeah you know they might
be the people you grew up with you have
some level of contact with them but it's
just night and day difference in your
lives right they're single they're going
here and you're raising a kid that you
know there would be some differences in
lifestyle to where you guys wouldn't be
on the same page a lot of the time have
you guys ever
ever off yeah yeah because they
only where you didn't like the way yeah
yeah yeah
what were they doing
stuff
very bad stuff like what what very
tempting naughty stuff
um just
not
can I say it honey yeah go ahead extreme
drugs basically yes yeah
ton of that and
not just that like other stuff that goes
along with it that that sort of way of
life brings and it does whether you're
you set yourself or you use or whatever
it is whatever it brings so
and once you step out of stuff like that
like once you change your life around
once you step out of like situations
like that you can look back on it and
you think what the hell was I doing with
you or was I only friends of you because
of this situation or we were both yeah
at this point in our lives together huh
like is that why we're friends or are we
actually friends because yeah why so
sometimes it is best to cut people off
for not it's not nice in any way shape
or form to do so I don't think I think
it's wise actually it is like I mean
there's there's been times where girls
are doing some like crazy [__] I'm like
I cannot be around because then people
are going to think I'm doing it exactly
that that's the thing exactly so if
you're associated with it then they
think you're doing it exactly that and
yeah if you are associated with certain
people it's like they say you can put a
nice Apple in in a bowl or you can put a
rotten but throat in a life let me start
the sentence again a rotten piece of
fruit in like a nice ripe fruit bowl buy
give it away every single favorite bread
mold spreads and it's all going to be
rotten yeah I mean any site they say
like you are you what what you what you
do who you surround yourself with is it
shapes you as an individual completely
and utterly like it shapes you in every
single way whether that be your home
life whether that be your work life your
family environment your just anything
that you do anything that you do in any
way that you act in any way you leave it
it does shape you as an individual and
sometimes yeah in order for you to grow
you need to set boundaries and if people
aren't willing to respect the boundaries
that you set then are they are they
really your friend or are they just
someone that is around because it's a
one an acquaintance or a round because
it's beneficial to them whether that be
mentally physically or financially so
yeah I would say
it's not nice cutting friends off
because
when you share like parts of your life
with someone or whether it be platonic
or relationship-wise whatever you give
yourself a part of that person and yeah
that part is something you'll never get
back yeah yeah also what are your morals
and your values right I think something
to quote Andrew Tate he says what do you
stand for and how like firm do you stand
on that right if you have such different
values then you're not that firm on your
values or your morals right so
enforcing that to an extent on yourself
and your life and the people you share
that with it shows how serious you are
kind of something Dimitri said was the
gray area and black and white I think so
that's something that's black and white
because it shows How firm you are for
yourself on those things are you loose
are you okay with whatever or do you
have a strong set of expectations strong
set of value strong yeah
what are you guys's biggest frustrations
in the dating market today
I would say
how common
degeneracy is in a cultural setting
you know like I was saying vaping is so
normal clubbing I hate vaping for me
that's the the biggest red flag that's
one thing I see and there's there's
nothing more to talk about but yeah
vaping uh clubbing just these type of
behaviors that are so normalized but uh
unfortunately I I don't see them as
conducive to high quality relationships
romantic or otherwise
what about you guys
um for me yeah going out all the time
partying drugs
um at surgery like I'm yeah I'm not
really good one yeah I'm not on any of
that at all I'm so far away from
from that kind of Lifestyle now so yeah
what about you someone know morals no
drive yeah no ambition just wants to do
partying don't want to go festival and
do this that the elbow doesn't think
about like the future there's a fly by
night I would say well and it's a really
selfish point of view too because it's
like you're going into a situation where
guys are trying to sleep with you
constantly so it kind of shows you don't
think about anyone else but yourself
especially if you're doing that like in
a relationship pleasure seeking yeah and
like that's the thing about the culture
and especially like women today I just
think we've been so coddled by like
stamps that nobody ever tells us the
truth about anything and that we we've
just been developed into like these me
me archetypes where it's like we really
just don't think about anyone else I do
what I want what makes me happy what I
feel like that's one of the biggest
things what I feel like I don't want to
lose myself oh my and it's like you're
supposed to lose parts of yourself in a
relationship like you're not supposed to
move the same at 22 is at 32. but the
men know this like the men do some wild
in there like teens and they'll be like
I had to grow up but it's like it's so
weird because you'll see grown women
acting the same way they did when they
were like 21. like even when you're
saying aunties like what are aunties
doing in the club
you're not supposed to be here like
you're supposed to have left 10 years
ago do we want clubs for people over 40
no
it's not kind of like the cool aunties
right yeah
yeah my auntie's uh yeah around to being
between 35 to 40. I mean what are they
doing at 35 to 40. you should have been
married like like 10 years all married
yeah I know maybe still still living the
the younger life a little bit Yeah but
that's that's the point they're still
moving so what age do you think is the
age that you should stop part like you
should forget that like forget partying
like in a hole I'm the wrong person to
ask because I would say past teenage
years old Hold You by the way hold it
hold you I'm 25.
I think I
I when you become a mom yeah yeah yeah
yeah I think I think that should be cut
off number one it's time to not live
like a teenager when you become a mom I
I don't think it's so much about you not
going that full stop leave it's not
about not having a social life it's just
about just knowing the boundaries at the
end of the day like you've still got go
out have a good time but it can't be
every every other day every weekend
that's just too much especially if
you're in a in a committed relationship
with with childhood well there's a
difference between like going out to
dinner with your like girlfriends and
like going to a club where everyone's
twerking and like I was just about to
say that the structure of the
socializing really matters like yeah
dinner versus like a degenerate uh
nightclub environment I mean I just
think like if you look at the trends for
like it's really interesting like when I
get to see stuff in real life because if
you look at the trends for like divorce
and like the lack of people getting
married and the increase in divorce it
really just kind of lines up with the
generation of women our grandmothers
didn't do this [__] it really started
with like our moms maybe a young Grandma
but like mostly the mothers they really
didn't teach us anything about being a
wife like to me to me it's like it's
crazy how many girls come on the show
and like don't realize they have to stop
going out when they get married
the reality is it's not so much about
the fun aspect yeah everyone needs to be
able to have fun at whatever age but
it's funny how when we we say people
should stop going to Club at a certain
age people automatically think towards
the phone it's more about the fact that
going to a club is a high risk activity
the older you get you should become
smarter you should you should stop
putting yourselves in situations where
if you could get killed where you could
get robbed like the clubs literally
a place where you can't defend yourself
if things go wrong like why would you
intentionally put yourself in that
position and then add alcohol into the
mix where you are you are now inhibited
you can't make right decisions like
that's crazy for an adult who has lived
life and seen experiences unless you're
just coasting through life and not
caring about your future I think like
these are these are things that should
be left to like your younger years at
the end of the day
um I'm going to read Super Chat
um guys make sure you like the video
um also subscribe to the channel okay Dr
David Baker if women said I just want to
be a wife and a mother I'd view it as a
green flag if she was otherwise an
attractive caring woman but my head
would immediately explode with figuring
out the economics of pulling it off they
match or let me translate modern women's
masculine
Resolute unflinching moral man equals a
narcissist okay and then let me refresh
it really quick
um
okay I think we're gonna close out the
show so we're gonna do final thoughts
and then you guys can plug any social
media you have so starting here and then
go around
one of those
we're supposed to have done something
like this it's quite exciting yeah
I'm sorry um
it's nice to be able to actually dip and
dive into conversations that'll probably
be a bit Taboo in normal day-to-day
conversation and it's nice to hear
everyone's so opinionated nowadays and
like you said people follow along with
different opinions and
it's nice to hear it from different
perspectives
and and you're not wrong women do lie
about everything new enough but we try
and hide it we try our best out of it
why do ourselves oh yeah we do yeah try
and justify things but it doesn't make
it any better but um yeah and if anyone
wants to follow me my app for Instagram
is Hannah Eason h-a-wn a-h-e-i-s-t-o-m
So yeah thank you
yeah it's the same what Hannah said
really it's nice to hear different
aspects of like I just feel like my
mindset and maybe I still might have a
young mentality
so it's nice to hear all the mentality
and the older mindset and the more
mature mindset
um on how you view relationships and
what the do's and don'ts in marriage
um yeah
oh and my Instagram tier.t
I would say final thoughts I think
it's a good thing that we're challenging
a little bit the the mainstream beliefs
the mainstream culture because if it's
not done on a platform like this uh it's
shy in in Daily Society so it needs to
have some discourse some challenge to
really kind of figure out what is the
correct way to go about things
especially as a society on a societal
level
I think the way we're going is clearly
not working 100 so things important
conversations we're having social media
Instagram anoosh buffai
a-n-o-o-s-h-v-a-f-a-e-i holistic health
and lifestyle coach anyone wants to
improve that
shout me
all right hey what's up uh so first of
all I'm gonna just plug a ram called the
greatest oil and gas company in the
world and why am I doing okay I'll tell
you why because they watch Pearl and
they love Pearl and I got a chance to
hang out them today and they're great
you guys are awesome thank you for
uh bringing sanity back into the
corporate world which is losing sanity
uh you guys know me I am Dimitri CEO of
lgfg fashion house our company sells and
markets high-end bespoke suits to all
the top players in the world of course
you guys see us on Jordan Peterson you
guys see us on uh zubi on Eddie Hall I'm
going up to see Tommy Fury deliver his
suits tomorrow so that's the kind of
people we work with me soon uh that's
right yeah we did the first fitting
yesterday so um which was very cool
um why I'm on the show is to tell people
about our company we recruit young
people that are coming out of college
that are college age maybe don't want to
go to college that are looking for a way
to build their financial future and if
your goal is to be rich and play lots of
girls I'm not the I'm not the guy for
you we're not the company for you but if
you want to build yourself as a man or
woman uh build a client base make great
money and then settle into a wonderful
life raising a family with lots of
beautiful kids then uh check out LGBT
fashion house we might be a good place
for you to apply for work
just want to say thank you for the
opportunity to come on tonight sure
everyone share our views and all that my
Instagram plugin is 29 Matthews on
Instagram
yeah I feel this has been very
insightful and I think more
opportunities need to be met like this
by such a great platform really giving
good Cadence to real topics and real
conversations
um today's been again really insightful
and just trying to
get that that Level Playing Field uh
like mindset of male and female like out
there so yeah I think it's been great
and I appreciate you also
um oh sorry social media um frosted us
Inc or Instagram and stuff for us yeah
thank you all for coming
um guys make sure you like the video on
your way out uh let's try to get a
thousand likes on the way out
um that is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these
streams a couple announcements just
before we end the show Fourth tier sign
up for my fourth tier you get a
one-on-one call with me once a month
wanna know how to get 1.5 million Subs
in a year
sign up for my fourth call I'll tell you
um also guys my ten dollar tier you get
to see me freestyle rapping in our
behind the scenes blog so sign up for
our behind the scenes videos uh third
tier you get to connect with me on
social media also guys subscribe to wife
school
um we're gonna do a new episode of King
teaching me jollof rice soon so I'm sign
up to see that like the video on your
way out also we have we're gonna have a
new Talent at jpt Network soon so stay
tuned like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel I'll talk to
you next time
woo oh